You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an|||你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多。每天看书、处在昏暗光线中、长时间看屏幕——这事我经常遇到。开车时阳光刺眼，甚至夜间开车也会导致视疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛经受了很大压力。因此，通过定期眼科检查来照顾它们并监测其健康状况非常重要。来 Specsavers 做一次99美元起的眼科检查，以检查它们的健康状况，其中包含 OCT 眼部健康扫描，这有助于在早期阶段检测出眼部及身体健康状况。若想寻找离你最近的门店，并预约
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.ca. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi there.
OCT 扫描起步价为 99 美元，请访问 specksavers.ca。眼科检查由独立验光师提供。价格可能因门店而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量 BFF（死党）故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0 版。你好。嗨。
We have a really fun Office Lady 6.0 today. We do. It is all about Kevin Malone with special guest Brian Baumgartner. Yeah. In the studio. In studio. Well, I want to kick things off with this fan question from Darya R in Port Perry, Ontario, Canada. Daria asks, where is Kevin really from?
We have a really fun Office Lady 6.0 today. We do. It is all about Kevin Malone with special guest Brian Baumgartner. Yeah. In the studio. In studio. Well, I want to kick things off with this fan question from Darya R in Port Perry, Ontario, Canada. Darya asks, where is Kevin really from?|||我们今天有一期非常有趣的《办公室女士》6.0。确实如此。这期节目完全是关于凯文·马隆（Kevin Malone）的，特别嘉宾是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）。是的。在录音室里。在录音室里。那么，我想用加拿大安大略省佩里港（Port Perry）的达里亚·R（Darya R）提出的这个粉丝问题来拉开序幕。达里亚问，凯文到底是哪里人？
There are so many misconceptions. In one episode, Michael says, quote, men from Scranton when referring to Kevin, but in delivery part two, Kevin says he's not from Scranton. What is with that? Is there anything in the show Bible? Seriously, what's up with that? Well, there's nothing specific about where he is from in the show Bible. It does list his current address, which is very specific. specific. It's one 668 summit point. It also lists his vehicle. A silver CRV. No, I could see him driving a silver CRV. You could? Yeah. Well, he does. Well, there you know. So that's good. Okay. It also lists his job as accountant. However, in Scott's Tots, remember, we learned he first applied for a job in the warehouse, but Michael hired him as an accountant because he had,
There are so many misconceptions. In one episode, Michael says, quote, men from Scranton when referring to Kevin, but in delivery part two, Kevin says he's not from Scranton. What is with that? Is there anything in the show Bible? Seriously, what's up with that? Well, there's nothing specific about where he is from in the show Bible. It does list his current address, which is very specific. specific. It's one 668 summit point. It also lists his vehicle. A silver CRV. No, I could see him driving a silver CRV. You could? Yeah. Well, he does. Well, there you know. So that's good. Okay. It also lists his job as accountant. However, in Scott's Tots, remember, we learned he first applied for a job in the warehouse, but Michael hired him as an accountant because he had,|||这里面有太多的误解了。在一集中，迈克尔在提到凯文时说的是，引述：“来自斯克兰顿的男人”，但在《分娩（下）》中，凯文却说他不是斯克兰顿人。这到底是怎么回事？剧集圣经里有提到这一点吗？说真的，这到底是怎么回事？嗯，剧集圣经里并没有具体说明他是哪里人。它确实列出了他的现住址，非常具体。具体来说是萨米特角 1668 号（1668 Summit Point）。它还列出了他的座驾。一辆银色 CR-V。不，我能想象他开一辆银色 CR-V 的样子。你能？对。嗯，他确实开这个。好吧，你知道的。那挺好的。好吧。它还将他的工作列为会计。然而，在《斯科特的 Tots》那一集里，大家还记得吗，我们了解到他最初是申请仓库的工作，但迈克尔录用他当会计，因为他当时……
quote, a feeling about him. But then he does have a diploma by his desk that says he got his associate of science degree in accounting from an online university called Penn Foster College. Penn Foster is a real college where people can get their degree online. What is the science of accounting? Is that like the math course I took in college called Ideas of Mathematics? Is accounting a science degree? There's like you can get your Bachelor of Arts or your Bachelor. of science. So does accounting, because it's part of math, fall under science? Are these like, you know what I mean? Like, I have a theater degree that fell under Bachelor of Arts. Right. Accounting is considered both a science and an art. Oh, did you Google that? Or is that your
quote, a feeling about him. But then he does have a diploma by his desk that says he got his associate of science degree in accounting from an online university called Penn Foster College. Penn Foster is a real college where people can get their degree online. What is the science of accounting? Is that like the math course I took in college called Ideas of Mathematics? Is accounting a science degree? There's like you can get your Bachelor of Arts or your Bachelor. of science. So does accounting, because it's part of math, fall under science? Are these like, you know what I mean? Like, I have a theater degree that fell under Bachelor of Arts. Right. Accounting is considered both a science and an art. Oh, did you Google that? Or is that your|||引述：“对他有一种感觉”。但随后他的办公桌旁确实挂着一张文凭，上面显示他在一所名叫宾福斯特学院（Penn Foster College）的在线大学获得了会计学副学士学位。宾福斯特是一所真正的大学，人们可以在那里在线获得学位。什么是会计科学？这就像我上大学时修的那门叫“数学思想”的数学课吗？会计是理学学位吗？就像你可以获得文学士或理学士学位一样。那么会计因为是数学的一部分，所以属于理学吗？这些就像是……你知道我的意思吗？比如，我的戏剧学位就属于文学士。没错。会计学既被认为是一门科学，也被认为是一门艺术。哦，这是你 Google 查的吗？还是你的……
personal opinion? No, no. That's what Google has to say. Thank you, Sam. All right. Okay, there you go. So, Darya, I'm sorry I can't answer your specific question, but you did cause me to open up the show Bible and I felt that I should do a show Bible summary of Kevin Malone. Well, I was hoping you would. So yay, Darya. I'll have you know the very first line of Kevin's show Bible says, quote, suffers from anal fissures. Oh, Kevin. That's the very first thing, the show Bible tells us about that. That's what it says. But here's your summary. Kevin. always sets the thermostat to 69 degrees. And then giggles.
personal opinion? No, no. That's what Google has to say. Thank you, Sam. All right. Okay, there you go. So, Darya, I'm sorry I can't answer your specific question, but you did cause me to open up the show Bible and I felt that I should do a show Bible summary of Kevin Malone. Well, I was hoping you would. So yay, Darya. I'll have you know the very first line of Kevin's show Bible says, quote, suffers from anal fissures. Oh, Kevin. That's the very first thing, the show Bible tells us about that. That's what it says. But here's your summary. Kevin. always sets the thermostat to 69 degrees. And then giggles.|||个人观点？不，不。那是 Google 上说的。谢谢你，萨姆。好啦。好吧，就这样。所以，达里亚，很抱歉我无法回答你的具体问题，但你确实让我打开了剧集圣经，我觉得我应该做一个关于凯文·马隆的剧集圣经总结。嗯，我正希望你这么做呢。所以，太棒了，达里亚。我要让你知道，凯文的剧集圣经的第一行写着，引述：“患有肛裂”。哦，凯文。那是剧集圣经告诉我们的关于他的第一件事。上面就是这么写的。但以下是你的总结。凯文总是把恒温器设在 69 度。然后咯咯地笑。
His favorite candy is M&Ms, and he wins the contest for putting the most in his mouth at one time. That's what she said. He loves them so much. He hid them from the Stanford transfer employees. He says he just cannot stop himself when it comes to M&Ms. His favorite lunch is cup of noodles. His favorite movie is American Pie 2.
His favorite candy is M&Ms, and he wins the contest for putting the most in his mouth at one time. That's what she said. He loves them so much. He hid them from the Stanford transfer employees. He says he just cannot stop himself when it comes to M&Ms. His favorite lunch is cup of noodles. His favorite movie is American Pie 2.|||他最喜欢的糖果是 M&M 豆，他还赢得了“一口气往嘴里塞最多糖果”的比赛。她就是这么说的。他太喜欢它们了。他把它们藏起来，不让斯坦福调来的员工看见。他说只要面对 M&M 豆，他就完全克制不住自己。他最喜欢的午餐是杯面。他最喜欢的电影是《美国派 2》。
Two. Not the first one. The second one. Very specific. He requires a magazine when giving a urine sample. Oh. He also takes off his tie when urinating and he doesn't wash his hands after using the restroom. We have a lot of information. Why don't we have so much bathroom info? I don't know on his bathroom habit. Why does he take off his tie? There was an episode I guess where he reveals he takes off his tie and he doesn't want it to dip in the toilet. Oh my gosh. I don't. I don't. I don't. I don't want the visual image of my brain. He was once engaged to be married to a woman named Stacey. Yeah, who has a daughter. Stacey was the fourth woman he had proposed to, and he secretly considered her his second choice. Him and Andy Bernard have a lot in common, actually. When it turns out. Love and romance.
Two. Not the first one. The second one. Very specific. He requires a magazine when giving a urine sample. Oh. He also takes off his tie when urinating and he doesn't wash his hands after using the restroom. We have a lot of information. Why don't we have so much bathroom info? I don't know on his bathroom habit. Why does he take off his tie? There was an episode I guess where he reveals he takes off his tie and he doesn't want it to dip in the toilet. Oh my gosh. I don't. I don't. I don't. I don't want the visual image of my brain. He was once engaged to be married to a woman named Stacey. Yeah, who has a daughter. Stacey was the fourth woman he had proposed to, and he secretly considered her his second choice. Him and Andy Bernard have a lot in common, actually. When it turns out. Love and romance.|||第二部。不是第一部。是第二部。非常具体。他在留尿样时需要一本杂志。哦。他小便时还会解下领带，而且他在上完厕所后不洗手。我们掌握了大量的信息。为什么我们会有这么多关于洗手间的信息？我不知道他的洗手间习惯。他为什么要解下领带？我猜有一集里他透露过，他解下领带是因为他不想让领带掉进马桶里。噢天哪。我不要。我不要。我不要。我不要这种视觉画面进入我的大脑。他曾与一个名叫斯黛西（Stacey）的女人订婚。对，她带着一个女儿。斯黛西是他向其求婚的第四个女人，而他私下里把她视为自己的第二选择。其实，他和安迪·伯纳德（Andy Bernard）有很多共同点。结果证明。爱与浪漫。
After Kevin and Stacey break up, he asks out Lynn, but we find out later she just wanted to be friends. He plays drums and sings in the band Scrantonicity, but they had a falling out, and so now his band is Scranticity, too. This leads me to a fan catch from Amelia T. in Bogota, Columbia. Amelia says, we need to get to the bottom of this, meaning Kevin's band. In the extended cut of basketball around the eight-minute mark, Kevin tells Dwight that he is in a Steve Miller tribute band, not a police cover band. Are we to believe he switches band genres at some point, or is this a continuity error? Well, Amelia, I'll tell you. Yes, he says Steve Miller tribute band in that deleted scene from basketball, which is now in the super fan episode.
After Kevin and Stacey break up, he asks out Lynn, but we find out later she just wanted to be friends. He plays drums and sings in the band Scrantonicity, but they had a falling out, and so now his band is Scranticity, too. This leads me to a fan catch from Amelia T. in Bogota, Columbia. Amelia says, we need to get to the bottom of this, meaning Kevin's band. In the extended cut of basketball around the eight-minute mark, Kevin tells Dwight that he is in a Steve Miller tribute band, not a police cover band. Are we to believe he switches band genres at some point, or is this a continuity error? Well, Amelia, I'll tell you. Yes, he says Steve Miller tribute band in that deleted scene from basketball, which is now in the super fan episode.|||在凯文和斯黛西分手后，他约了琳（Lynn），但我们后来发现她只想做朋友。他在“斯克兰托尼蒂”（Scrantonicity）乐队打鼓并担任主唱，但他们闹翻了，所以现在他的乐队是“斯克兰托尼蒂 2”（Scranticity 2）。这让我想到了哥伦比亚波哥大的阿梅莉亚·T（Amelia T.）发现的一个粉丝漏洞。阿梅莉亚说，我们需要弄清事情的真相，指的是凯文的乐队。在《篮球》加长版大约第八分钟的时候，凯文告诉德怀特他加入的是一个史蒂夫·米勒（Steve Miller）致敬乐队，而不是一个警察乐队（The Police）的翻唱乐队。我们要相信他在某个时候转换了乐队风格吗，还是这是一个连贯性错误？好吧，阿梅莉亚，我来告诉你。是的，他在《篮球》那个被删减的场景中确实说过是史蒂夫·米勒致敬乐队，这个片段现在收录在超级粉丝版剧集里。
It was always the writer's intention to have Kevin's band be a Steve Miller tribute band. I remember that. He tells Katie and Hot Girl that he's in a Steve Miller tribute band. She's not a fan. That's right. But when we film Casino Night, which is. is the episode where Pam and Jim watch videos of his band. We couldn't get permission from Steve Miller band to play their songs. Yeah, they said, uh-uh. We don't want to be on the office.
It was always the writer's intention to have Kevin's band be a Steve Miller tribute band. I remember that. He tells Katie and Hot Girl that he's in a Steve Miller tribute band. She's not a fan. That's right. But when we film Casino Night, which is. is the episode where Pam and Jim watch videos of his band. We couldn't get permission from Steve Miller band to play their songs. Yeah, they said, uh-uh. We don't want to be on the office.|||编剧的初衷一直是让凯文的乐队成为一个史蒂夫·米勒致敬乐队。我记得。他告诉凯蒂（Katie）和辣妹（Hot Girl）他在一个史蒂夫·米勒致敬乐队里。她不是粉丝。没错。但当我们拍摄《赌场之夜》时，也就是帕姆和吉姆观看他的乐队视频的那一集。我们无法获得史蒂夫·米勒乐队的许可来播放他们的歌曲。是的，他们说，呃-呃。我们不想出现在《办公室》里。
So we had to change it to the police. That's what happened. You want more Kevin info? Yeah. All right. I mean, we need to get to know Kevin very well. This is all about Kevin Malone. Well, I'm giving you all we know. Give it all to me. Kevin won the 2002, 2,500, no limit. seven draw tournament at the World Series of poker in Las Vegas. He's good at basketball. He's also good at trivia night. He is an avid gambler. He bets on sports. In fact, he uses petty cash to gamble at the golf course. But the thing he thinks he does best is making chili. He has also cooked his way through Julia Child's cookbook and part of the Twilight cookbook. He has an adopted dog named Ruby. And Kevin is also a loyal friend. He stood up to the state senator when he was mean to Oscar and Angela. He's the one who
So we had to change it to the police. That's what happened. You want more Kevin info? Yeah. All right. I mean, we need to get to know Kevin very well. This is all about Kevin Malone. Well, I'm giving you all we know. Give it all to me. Kevin won the 2002, 2,500, no limit. seven draw tournament at the World Series of poker in Las Vegas. He's good at basketball. He's also good at trivia night. He is an avid gambler. He bets on sports. In fact, he uses petty cash to gamble at the golf course. But the thing he thinks he does best is making chili. He has also cooked his way through Julia Child's cookbook and part of the Twilight cookbook. He has an adopted dog named Ruby. And Kevin is also a loyal friend. He stood up to the state senator when he was mean to Oscar and Angela. He's the one who|||所以我们不得不把它改成警察乐队（The Police）。事情就是这样。你想知道更多关于凯文的信息吗？想。好的。我的意思是，我们需要非常了解凯文。这期节目全都是关于凯文·马隆的。好吧，我把我们所知道的一切都告诉你。全都告诉我吧。凯文赢得了 2002 年拉斯维加斯世界扑克大赛（World Series of Poker）2500 美元无限注七张牌换牌锦标赛的冠军。他擅长打篮球。他也擅长益智问答之夜。他是一个狂热的赌徒。他赌球。事实上，他挪用零用钱在高尔夫球场赌博。但他认为自己做得最好的事情是做辣椒汤。他还按照朱莉娅·查尔斯（Julia Child）的食谱和部分《暮光之城》食谱做遍了里面的菜。他有一只名叫鲁比（Ruby）的收养犬。而且凯文也是一个忠诚的朋友。当州参议员对奥斯卡和安吉拉刻薄时，他挺身而出。他是那个……
noticed when Andy was suffering from a mental breakdown. He is, however, not a great accountant. He invented the number 11 and was eventually fired for incompetence. And Darya, as far as family, there is nothing in the show Bible, so we're going to have to look at some supplemental office content. There isn't much. But in the webisode, the podcast, Kevin says he is Irish. And there is a deleted scene from Andy's play that, Angela, you mentioned when we broke down that episode where we learned Kevin has a sister who is actually in the play. In the play, yeah. Let's listen.
noticed when Andy was suffering from a mental breakdown. He is, however, not a great accountant. He invented the number 11 and was eventually fired for incompetence. And Darya, as far as family, there is nothing in the show Bible, so we're going to have to look at some supplemental office content. There isn't much. But in the webisode, the podcast, Kevin says he is Irish. And there is a deleted scene from Andy's play that, Angela, you mentioned when we broke down that episode where we learned Kevin has a sister who is actually in the play. In the play, yeah. Let's listen.|||注意到安迪精神崩溃的人。然而，他并不是一个出色的会计。他发明了数字 11，并最终因不称职而被解雇。达里亚，至于家庭方面，剧集圣经里没有任何记载，所以我们只能看看一些《办公室》的补充内容。内容不多。但在网络剧集《播客》中，凯文说他是爱尔兰人。安吉拉，正如你在我们剖析那一集时所提到的，安迪的话剧里有一个被删减的片段，我们在其中得知凯文有一个妹妹，她实际上就在那部话剧中。在话剧里，对。我们来听听。
Hi. Kevin. Hi. Stuart, this is my brother Kevin. Hi. I can't believe you came to every show. You are good. Oh, thank you. See, you never come to anything I ever do. So what's the change?
Hi. Kevin. Hi. Stuart, this is my brother Kevin. Hi. I can't believe you came to every show. You are good. Oh, thank you. See, you never come to anything I ever do. So what's the change?|||嗨。凯文。嗨。斯图尔特，这是我哥哥凯文。嗨。真不敢相信你每场演出都来了。你真不错。哦，谢谢。你看，我做什么你从来都不来。那这次怎么变了？
We need to put mom in a home. So we learned a little bit there about his sister and his mom. Yeah, but that's all there is. We only meet her through that deleted scene. And it's probably why she didn't make it into the show Bible. And listen, we do ask Brian about this in our interview coming up later in the episode, and he does share some reasons why we don't know more about Kevin's backstory. So stay tuned. Well, I love me some show Bible, lady. It always delivers. Well, I thought we can't talk about all about Kevin Malone without discussing that classic chilly cold open written by Aaron Scher.
We need to put mom in a home. So we learned a little bit there about his sister and his mom. Yeah, but that's all there is. We only meet her through that deleted scene. And it's probably why she didn't make it into the show Bible. And listen, we do ask Brian about this in our interview coming up later in the episode, and he does share some reasons why we don't know more about Kevin's backstory. So stay tuned. Well, I love me some show Bible, lady. It always delivers. Well, I thought we can't talk about all about Kevin Malone without discussing that classic chilly cold open written by Aaron Scher.|||我们得把妈妈送进养老院了。所以我们在那里了解了一点关于他妹妹和妈妈的信息。是的，但也就这些了。我们只能通过那个被删减的片段认识她。这大概也是她没有被写入剧集圣经的原因。听着，我们在本集稍后的采访中确实问过布莱恩这个问题，他也分享了一些为什么我们对凯文的背景故事知之甚少的原委。所以请继续收听。嗯，我太喜欢剧集圣经了，女士。它总是干货满满。好吧，我想我们在讨论关于凯文·马隆的一切时，绝对不能不讨论由亚伦·谢尔（Aaron Shure）所写的那个经典的辣椒汤开场白。
You guys know it's the scene that kicks off Season 5 episode Casual Friday. Brian once said in an interview that this scene is, quote, about an ordinary guy who doesn't do a lot well, but he does chili well. And obviously, it doesn't succeed. But you hear in his voice how excited he is to be sharing this thing that he does well. And then Kevin, of course, says it's probably the thing I do best. Brian said he gets asked about this scene all the time of all the things that he's done on the office. I mean, he wrote a whole chili cookbook. Yes, he did.
You guys know it's the scene that kicks off Season 5 episode Casual Friday. Brian once said in an interview that this scene is, quote, about an ordinary guy who doesn't do a lot well, but he does chili well. And obviously, it doesn't succeed. But you hear in his voice how excited he is to be sharing this thing that he does well. And then Kevin, of course, says it's probably the thing I do best. Brian said he gets asked about this scene all the time of all the things that he's done on the office. I mean, he wrote a whole chili cookbook. Yes, he did.|||大家知道，这就是拉开第五季《休闲星期五》那一集序幕的场景。布莱恩曾在一次采访中说，这个场景是，引述：“关于一个普通人，他很多事情都做不好，但他辣椒汤做得很棒。显然，这并没有成功。但你从他的声音中能听到，当他分享这件他擅长的事情时，他是多么兴奋。”然后凯文当然会说，这可能是他做得最好的事情。布莱恩说，在他在《办公室》里做过的所有事情中，人们总是向他问起这个场景。我的意思是，他写了一整本辣椒汤食谱。是的，他写了。
He did. And, you know, I've traveled a lot with Brian. We often got paired up to travel, and it is something people just really connect with him about. And they have put Kevin smelling the chili. I have seen it on a tattoo on someone's leg. Same. Yeah. On T-shirts, on baby onesies, on a birthday cake.
He did. And, you know, I've traveled a lot with Brian. We often got paired up to travel, and it is something people just really connect with him about. And they have put Kevin smelling the chili. I have seen it on a tattoo on someone's leg. Same. Yeah. On T-shirts, on baby onesies, on a birthday cake.|||他确实写了。而且，你知道的，我和布莱恩一起旅行过很多次。我们经常被分在一组去旅行，而这正是人们真正能与他产生共鸣的事。他们还把凯文闻辣椒汤的画面……我在某人的腿上的纹身上见过。我也是。对。印在T恤上、婴儿连体衣上、生日蛋糕上。
It's just, it's very popular. And I thought, you know, we can't do this episode without actually having Kevin's chili. Brian put it in his chili cookbook. It's called Kevin's Famous Chili. I asked Josh if he could make it last night. And he did. And it's really good. I mean, the way he describes it.
It's just, it's very popular. And I thought, you know, we can't do this episode without actually having Kevin's chili. Brian put it in his chili cookbook. It's called Kevin's Famous Chili. I asked Josh if he could make it last night. And he did. And it's really good. I mean, the way he describes it.|||总之，非常受欢迎。我想，你知道的，我们做这期节目不能没有真正的凯文辣椒汤。布莱恩把它写进了他的辣椒汤食谱里。它叫“凯文的著名辣椒汤”。我昨晚问乔希能不能做一下。他做了。而且真的很好吃。我是说，看他描述的方式。
With the onions and the things, like, yes, I thought we had to hear it. At least once a year, I like to bring in some of my Kevin's famous chili. The trick is to undercook the onions. Everybody is going to get to know each other in the pot. I'm serious about this stuff. I'm up the night before, pressing garlic and dicing whole tomato. I toast my own anchro chilies. It's a recipe passed down from Malones for generations.
With the onions and the things, like, yes, I thought we had to hear it. At least once a year, I like to bring in some of my Kevin's famous chili. The trick is to undercook the onions. Everybody is going to get to know each other in the pot. I'm serious about this stuff. I'm up the night before, pressing garlic and dicing whole tomato. I toast my own anchro chilies. It's a recipe passed down from Malones for generations.|||加上洋葱和其他食材，就像……是的，我觉得我们必须听一下。至少一年有一次，我喜欢带一些我做的“凯文著名辣椒汤”来。秘诀是不要把洋葱煮得太熟。每个人都会在锅里互相认识的。我对这事可是认真的。我在前一天晚上熬夜压蒜、把整只番茄切丁。我自己烘烤安乔辣椒（anchro chilies）。这是马隆家族代代相传的食谱。
It's probably the thing I do best. I mean, I'm so excited. You told me that Josh was doing this, and I wrote you back and I said, this is my lunch today. I packed no lunch. This is what I want to eat. Please bring this chili in. I do want to tell you guys, we talked in such depth about this scene, how we made this scene in the episode Casual Friday. So if you haven't heard it, it's a great listen.
It's probably the thing I do best. I mean, I'm so excited. You told me that Josh was doing this, and I wrote you back and I said, this is my lunch today. I packed no lunch. This is what I want to eat. Please bring this chili in. I do want to tell you guys, we talked in such depth about this scene, how we made this scene in the episode Casual Friday. So if you haven't heard it, it's a great listen.|||这可能是我做得最好的事了。我是说，我太兴奋了。你告诉我乔希在做这个时，我回信说，这就是我今天的午餐。我没带午餐。这就是我想吃的。请把这个辣椒汤带过来。我确实想告诉大家，我们非常深入地讨论了这个场景，以及我们在《休闲星期五》这一集中是如何制作这个场景的。所以如果你还没听过，那非常值得一听。
It is. We got a lot of good insight scoop from Aaron Scher and also from Brian. Yeah. Well, I did bring chili today. I brought Kevin's famous chili out of Brian's cookbook, seriously good chili cookbook. I'm going to go heat it up. All right. Well, why don't we take a break?
It is. We got a lot of good insight scoop from Aaron Scher and also from Brian. Yeah. Well, I did bring chili today. I brought Kevin's famous chili out of Brian's cookbook, seriously good chili cookbook. I'm going to go heat it up. All right. Well, why don't we take a break?|||确实如此。我们从亚伦·谢尔以及布莱恩那里得到了很多精彩的独家内幕。是的。好吧，我今天确实带来了辣椒汤。我用布莱恩的食谱——那本《极其美味的辣椒汤食谱》（Seriously Good Chili Cookbook）——做了“凯文的著名辣椒汤”。我要去把它加热一下。好的。那么，我们为什么不休息一下呢？
And when we come back, we're going to eat some chili. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah.
And when we come back, we're going to eat some chili. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah.|||等我们回来后，就要吃辣椒汤了。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，新年新气象并不意味着你必须脱胎换骨变成一个崭新的自己。但也许你想卸下更多负担，变得思路更清晰。是的。不是完全变成另一个人，也许你只是想专注于某事。你想进行自我精修。是的。
I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationship. your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up.
I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationship. your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up.|||我喜欢这个词：精修。嗯，心理治疗可以帮助你更轻松地识别是什么在压垮你，是什么在拖你的后腿。你能更好地理解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。我正在努力不再为一些小事感到压力山大。嗯。因为那些琐事真的会不断累积。
Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. Mm-hmm. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist.
Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. Mm-hmm. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist.|||嗯。而且事情会没问题的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。嗯。BetterHelp 的治疗师可以帮到你。拥有超过 3万名治疗师，BetterHelp 是全球最大的在线心理治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供过服务。BetterHelp让你能轻松在网上匹配到合格的治疗师。
sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies. Right, we are back and we are eating Kevin's famous chili. Thank you, Josh. I know. It's really good. Really good. There's something about chili that just makes you feel cozy, doesn't it? Yes. This has like exactly the right amount of spice for me. I get a little kick, but it's not overpowering. And what is this, is this the ale? Doesn't it calls for lager, right? Is that what this taste is?
sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies. Right, we are back and we are eating Kevin's famous chili. Thank you, Josh. I know. It's really good. Really good. There's something about chili that just makes you feel cozy, doesn't it? Yes. This has like exactly the right amount of spice for me. I get a little kick, but it's not overpowering. And what is this, is this the ale? Doesn't it calls for lager, right? Is that what this taste is?|||注册并在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 购买即可享受 90% 的优惠（注：此处原文说的是 10% off，即九折）。网址是 better h-e-l-p.com 斜杠 office ladies。好，我们回来了，正在吃凯文著名的辣椒汤。谢谢你，乔希。我知道。真的很好吃。非常美味。辣椒汤总有一种能让人感到温暖惬意的魔力，对吧？是的。对我来说，这个辣度刚刚好。有一点刺激感，但又不会太冲。这是什么，这是麦芽酒（ale）吗？它不是需要拉格啤酒（lager）吗，对吧？这味道是那个吗？
I don't know. I like it. The thinly diced onions really make a difference. You know what? They all got to know each other in the pot. They did. And they're making me very happy. Mm-hmm.
I don't know. I like it. The thinly diced onions really make a difference. You know what? They all got to know each other in the pot. They did. And they're making me very happy. Mm-hmm.|||我不知道。我喜欢它。切得薄薄的洋葱确实起到了关键作用。你知道吗？它们都在锅里互相认识了。确实如此。它们让我感到非常快乐。嗯。
Mm. I think we should mention, Cassie, you are unable to try this chili because you're joining us on Zoom today. I'm so sorry. Yeah. Is it vegetarian? I was going to say, Cassie, if you were here, we would have made a vegetarian option. Oh, yeah. It is not vegetarian.
Mm. I think we should mention, Cassie, you are unable to try this chili because you're joining us on Zoom today. I'm so sorry. Yeah. Is it vegetarian? I was going to say, Cassie, if you were here, we would have made a vegetarian option. Oh, yeah. It is not vegetarian.|||嗯。我觉得我们应该提一下，卡西，你今天因为是通过 Zoom 参加我们的节目，所以尝不到这碗辣椒汤了。真替你遗憾。对。它是素食的吗？我正要说呢，卡西，如果你在这里，我们本可以做一个素食版本的。哦，对。它不是素食的。
Kevin's recipe is not. I would assume not. Well, that was incredible and very satisfying. And I thank Josh. And I thank Brian Baumgartner for putting that in his cookbook. And Kevin. And Kevin. And Aaron, sure, I guess, for writing the cold open.
Kevin's recipe is not. I would assume not. Well, that was incredible and very satisfying. And I thank Josh. And I thank Brian Baumgartner for putting that in his cookbook. And Kevin. And Kevin. And Aaron, sure, I guess, for writing the cold open.|||凯文的食谱不是。我猜也不是。嗯，这真是太棒了，也非常满足。我要感谢乔希。我要感谢布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳把它写进他的食谱里。还有凯文。还有凯文。我想还要感谢亚伦·谢尔写了那个开场白。
There's lots of people to thank. Ah. All right. Well, I'm going to put this away now. and I am going to get into, I guess what I'm calling my deep dive area of interest. We each picked one. We each picked a topic about Kevin we wanted to explore. I wanted to explore the evolution of Kevin.
There's lots of people to thank. Ah. All right. Well, I'm going to put this away now. and I am going to get into, I guess what I'm calling my deep dive area of interest. We each picked one. We each picked a topic about Kevin we wanted to explore. I wanted to explore the evolution of Kevin.|||有太多人要感谢了。啊。好吧。嗯，我现在要把这个收起来了，然后我要进入……我猜可以称之为我感兴趣的深度剖析领域。我们每人选了一个。我们每人都选了一个关于凯文的主题来探讨。我想探讨的是凯文的演变。
Oh. There's a lot of articles about it. We got a lot of fan mail about it. So I was really intrigued. I mean, it sounds like a very fancy title, The Evolution of Kevin. Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you so much.
Oh. There's a lot of articles about it. We got a lot of fan mail about it. So I was really intrigued. I mean, it sounds like a very fancy title, The Evolution of Kevin. Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you so much.|||哦。有很多关于这方面的文章。我们收到了很多关于这方面的粉丝来信。所以我真的很感兴趣。我的意思是，这听起来像是一个非常高级的标题：《凯文的演变》。谢谢。不客气。非常感谢。
You know, initially, the character of Kevin was mostly used for cutaway gags or, like, funny one-liners. He was painted with a pretty broad brush. I was going through old episodes, and there's that episode from season two, drug testing, and it's where Dwight is questioning Kevin about the joint that was found in the parking lot. I thought that this was a really good example of how the character of Kevin was used early on. So I thought we could listen to it. Okay. Let's go over some of these symptoms of marijuana use, shall we?
You know, initially, the character of Kevin was mostly used for cutaway gags or, like, funny one-liners. He was painted with a pretty broad brush. I was going through old episodes, and there's that episode from season two, drug testing, and it's where Dwight is questioning Kevin about the joint that was found in the parking lot. I thought that this was a really good example of how the character of Kevin was used early on. So I thought we could listen to it. Okay. Let's go over some of these symptoms of marijuana use, shall we?|||你知道，最初，凯文这个角色主要用于过场插话或搞笑的妙语。对他的刻画比较粗线条。我当时在回顾旧剧集，第二季里有一集叫《药物测试》，讲的是德怀特就停车场发现的大麻烟卷质问凯文。我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明了早期凯文这个角色是如何被使用的。所以我想我们可以听一下。好的。我们来回顾一下大麻使用的一些症状，好吗？
You tell me who this sounds like. Slow moving, inattentive, dull, constantly snacking, shows a lack of motivation. Hey. That's it. His line is, hey. It's the same way he says Stacy. Yeah. Sorry, I'm still eating chili. I'm sorry. We're supposed to put that down, but it's hard to resist. I know. Also, I know there's some people who really have a hard time listening to other people eat or chew. It's like a thing. So many apologies. I'm going to stop eating now. Okay. If you can. I know. Okay. We got this fan question from Layton R in Folsom, California, who says, Kevin has some of the funniest one like.
You tell me who this sounds like. Slow moving, inattentive, dull, constantly snacking, shows a lack of motivation. Hey. That's it. His line is, hey. It's the same way he says Stacy. Yeah. Sorry, I'm still eating chili. I'm sorry. We're supposed to put that down, but it's hard to resist. I know. Also, I know there's some people who really have a hard time listening to other people eat or chew. It's like a thing. So many apologies. I'm going to stop eating now. Okay. If you can. I know. Okay. We got this fan question from Layton R in Folsom, California, who says, Kevin has some of the funniest one like.|||你们告诉我这听起来像谁。行动迟缓、注意力不集中、迟钝、不停吃零食、表现缺乏动力。嘿。就是这样。他的台词是，嘿。这和他叫斯黛西的语气一模一样。对。抱歉，我还在吃辣椒汤。对不起。我们本该把它放下的，但实在很难抗拒。我知道。另外，我知道有些人真的很讨厌听别人吃东西或咀嚼的声音。这就像是一种强迫症。非常抱歉。我现在就不吃了。好吧。如果你能做到的话。我知道。好吧。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州福尔松（Folsom）的莱顿·R（Layton R）的粉丝提问，他说，凯文在剧中有一些最有趣的单句台词……
on the show, which Kevin line or moment still makes you laugh the most when you think back on it. Well, I thought this was a great question, and so we threw it out to the group, and we thought everybody could share Sam, Cassie, and who wants to go first? I'll go first. Okay. So I'm a big fan of when Kevin first introduces why he's been going into Jim's office. Here, I'll play it for you. Okay.
on the show, which Kevin line or moment still makes you laugh the most when you think back on it. Well, I thought this was a great question, and so we threw it out to the group, and we thought everybody could share Sam, Cassie, and who wants to go first? I'll go first. Okay. So I'm a big fan of when Kevin first introduces why he's been going into Jim's office. Here, I'll play it for you. Okay.|||……凯文的哪一句台词或哪一个瞬间，当你想起来时依然会让你笑得最开心。嗯，我觉得这是一个很好的问题，所以我们把它抛给了大家，我们觉得每个人都可以分享一下，萨姆、卡西，谁想先来？我先来。好的。我非常喜欢凯文第一次解释他为什么一直去吉姆办公室的那一段。来，我放给你们听。好的。
Jim's gone on his honeymoon. So I started borrowing his office to fart in. Then one day I came in and I just stayed because this place is awesome. It feels like home now. Even better than my home. My home sucks. It's perfectly, Kevin. It's funny and so sad.
Jim's gone on his honeymoon. So I started borrowing his office to fart in. Then one day I came in and I just stayed because this place is awesome. It feels like home now. Even better than my home. My home sucks. It's perfectly, Kevin. It's funny and so sad.|||吉姆去度蜜月了。所以我开始借他的办公室去放屁。然后有一天我进来后就赖着不走了，因为这里太棒了。现在感觉就像家一样。甚至比我的家还要好。我的家太烂了。这太完美了，太凯文了。既好笑又好悲伤。
It's so tragic. Well, it's interesting because my favorite is from the episode right. before from Jim and Pam's wedding. Let me set it up for you. He's at the hotel and he's wearing his toupee and he's very proudly walking down the hall. Here's what he says. What an awesome party. The best wedding I've ever been to.
It's so tragic. Well, it's interesting because my favorite is from the episode right. before from Jim and Pam's wedding. Let me set it up for you. He's at the hotel and he's wearing his toupee and he's very proudly walking down the hall. Here's what he says. What an awesome party. The best wedding I've ever been to.|||太悲剧了。嗯，很有趣的是，我最喜欢的一段出自吉姆和帕姆婚礼前的那一集。我来给你们铺垫一下。他在酒店里，戴着假发，非常骄傲地走在走廊上。他是这么说的。多棒的派对啊。这是我参加过的最好的婚礼。
I got six numbers. One more would have been a complete telephone number. Yeah. He got six individual numbers from women. Yeah. one more and he would have had someone to call. He was so close. So close.
I got six numbers. One more would have been a complete telephone number. Yeah. He got six individual numbers from women. Yeah. one more and he would have had someone to call. He was so close. So close.|||我拿到了六个数字。再多一个就是一个完整的电话号码了。对。他从女人那里拿到了六个独立的数字。对。再有一个他就能打电话了。他就差一点了。太可惜了。
Cassie, do you want to go next? Sure. There's a lot of great Kevin moments and any scene with Kevin and Holly always cracks me up. But one we haven't talked about is in Mafia, how he frees his gym's credit card while on his honeymoon with Pam at Puerto Rico. That's so funny. That is so great. I forgot about that. Hello?
Cassie, do you want to go next? Sure. There's a lot of great Kevin moments and any scene with Kevin and Holly always cracks me up. But one we haven't talked about is in Mafia, how he frees his gym's credit card while on his honeymoon with Pam at Puerto Rico. That's so funny. That is so great. I forgot about that. Hello?|||卡西，你想接着说吗？当然。有很多精彩的凯文时刻，凯文和霍莉在一起的任何场景总是让我捧腹大笑。但我们还没聊到的一点是，在《黑手党》那一集里，他在波多黎各和帕姆度蜜月时，是如何冻结吉姆的信用卡的。太搞笑了。太棒了。我都把这事忘了。喂？
Hello, Mr. Halpert. I'm calling from the Identity Health Department at Capital One. We've detected some unusual activity on your credit card. Oh, man, do you think it was stolen? First, would you mind verifying your home address? Um, yes. Um, 383, Lyndon, Av, Scranton, PA. And may I have the last four digits of your Social Security?
Hello, Mr. Halpert. I'm calling from the Identity Health Department at Capital One. We've detected some unusual activity on your credit card. Oh, man, do you think it was stolen? First, would you mind verifying your home address? Um, yes. Um, 383, Lyndon, Av, Scranton, PA. And may I have the last four digits of your Social Security?|||喂，海尔珀特先生。我是第一资本（Capital One）身份健康部的。我们检测到您的信用卡有一些异常活动。哦，天哪，你觉得它是被偷了吗？首先，您介意核实一下您的家庭地址吗？嗯，好的。嗯，宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿林登大道 383 号。能告诉我您社会安全号的后四位吗？
6-650. Well, Mr. Halpert, you're obviously not in fact. San Juan, Puerto Rico. Wait a minute. Yes, I am. I'm going to go ahead and put a hold on your card. No, that, I think that we should let the criminal use the card a little longer. Very funny, sir.
6-650. Well, Mr. Halpert, you're obviously not in fact. San Juan, Puerto Rico. Wait a minute. Yes, I am. I'm going to go ahead and put a hold on your card. No, that, I think that we should let the criminal use the card a little longer. Very funny, sir.|||6-650。嗯，海尔珀特先生，您显然并没有身处……波多黎各圣胡安。等一下。没错，我就是。我要继续冻结您的卡了。不，我觉得我们应该让罪犯再多用一会儿这张卡。真幽默，先生。
We'll get a new card out to you right away. No. Have a nice day and thank you. His whimper at the end. Yeah, so good. Well, you guys, my favorite moment isn't so much like a funny line. It's more of a moment when he stood up for Amher. Angela. You sort of mentioned this earlier, Jenna, in your show Bible. It's from the episode
We'll get a new card out to you right away. No. Have a nice day and thank you. His whimper at the end. Yeah, so good. Well, you guys, my favorite moment isn't so much like a funny line. It's more of a moment when he stood up for Amher. Angela. You sort of mentioned this earlier, Jenna, in your show Bible. It's from the episode|||我们会立刻为您补办一张新卡。不。祝您过得愉快，谢谢。他最后发出的呜咽声。对，太棒了。各位，我最喜欢的时刻与其说是一句搞笑台词，不如说是一个他为安姆……安吉拉挺身而出的时刻。珍娜，你刚才在你的剧集圣经里稍微提到了这一点。它出自那一集……
vandalism. And, you know, the Senator and Angela have had all their fancy friends over to their house, and they're getting this group photo with Baby Philip. And Oscar and Angela are pushing each other and fighting to be in the front of the picture. And as they leave, Kevin stands up for them to the Senator. And here's the clip. Thank you so much. Well, have we all calmed down yet? Yes. Sorry about that. It was all my fault. Let's all try to do better next time. Kevin, great to see you.
vandalism. And, you know, the Senator and Angela have had all their fancy friends over to their house, and they're getting this group photo with Baby Philip. And Oscar and Angela are pushing each other and fighting to be in the front of the picture. And as they leave, Kevin stands up for them to the Senator. And here's the clip. Thank you so much. Well, have we all calmed down yet? Yes. Sorry about that. It was all my fault. Let's all try to do better next time. Kevin, great to see you.|||《破坏》派对。你知道的，参议员和安吉拉把他们那些有钱的朋友都请到了家里，他们正抱着小菲利普拍全家福。奥斯卡和安吉拉互相推搡，争抢着要站在照片的最前面。当他们离开时，凯文为他们向参议员打抱不平。片段如下。非常感谢。好了，大家现在都冷静下来了吗？冷静了。真对不起。这全怪我。大家下次都争取表现得更好。凯文，很高兴见到你。
Thank you for the food. And also, you suck. I beg your pardon. You are like a terrible person. These guys care about you and you're just using them. Again, the food was very good. And then Angela has a little smile. Well, Angie, Lauren G from Massachusetts wrote in, and this is also her favorite Kevin moment.
Thank you for the food. And also, you suck. I beg your pardon. You are like a terrible person. These guys care about you and you're just using them. Again, the food was very good. And then Angela has a little smile. Well, Angie, Lauren G from Massachusetts wrote in, and this is also her favorite Kevin moment.|||谢谢你的食物。还有，你真烂。请再说一遍。你简直是个糟糕透顶的人。这些人关心你，而你却只是在利用他们。再次声明，食物非常美味。然后安吉拉露出了一丝微笑。安吉，来自马萨诸塞州的劳伦·G（Lauren G）来信说，这也是她最喜欢的凯文时刻。
Not only that, Lauren said Kevin is one of my favorite characters. Lauren thinks that that moment is a humanizing moment. And it shows that Kevin is not just the office goofball, but that he loves people and he stands up for them. Yeah. And Lauren, Collider agrees with you. They actually put out an article in April of 2023 asking if Kevin was actually the heart of the office. Aw. Yeah.
Not only that, Lauren said Kevin is one of my favorite characters. Lauren thinks that that moment is a humanizing moment. And it shows that Kevin is not just the office goofball, but that he loves people and he stands up for them. Yeah. And Lauren, Collider agrees with you. They actually put out an article in April of 2023 asking if Kevin was actually the heart of the office. Aw. Yeah.|||不仅如此，劳伦说凯文是她最喜欢的角色之一。劳伦认为那个时刻是一个充满人情味的时刻。这表明凯文不仅仅是办公室里的活宝，他懂得爱别人，并会为他们挺身而出。是的。劳伦，Collider 网站（电影电视资讯网站）也同意你的观点。他们在 2023 年 4 月发表了一篇文章，探讨凯文是否实际上才是《办公室》的核心。哇。对。
And this is where we get into kind of the evolution of the character going from a guy who does silly one-liners to having so much more depth. The article points out that while Kevin may not be the smartest character, his simplicity and his genuine desire for happiness really resonated with audiences. Kevin is portrayed as a loyal friend who often lacks any kind of agenda. He just seeks laughter and connection rather than personal gain. And the article points out that while Kevin wanted to be liked, Michael kind of needed to be liked at like an obsessive level. And you also have characters like Dwight, Oscar, and Angela who really needed to feel superior to everybody. Jim was always kind of trying to impress Pam or make her laugh. But of all the characters, Kevin really just wants to live in the moment.
And this is where we get into kind of the evolution of the character going from a guy who does silly one-liners to having so much more depth. The article points out that while Kevin may not be the smartest character, his simplicity and his genuine desire for happiness really resonated with audiences. Kevin is portrayed as a loyal friend who often lacks any kind of agenda. He just seeks laughter and connection rather than personal gain. And the article points out that while Kevin wanted to be liked, Michael kind of needed to be liked at like an obsessive level. And you also have characters like Dwight, Oscar, and Angela who really needed to feel superior to everybody. Jim was always kind of trying to impress Pam or make her laugh. But of all the characters, Kevin really just wants to live in the moment.|||这就是我们所说的角色的演变过程，从一个只会说傻乎乎单句台词的人，转变为一个拥有如此多深度的角色。文章指出，虽然凯文可能不是最聪明的角色，但他的单纯和对快乐的真诚渴望真正引起了观众的共鸣。凯文被塑造成一个忠诚的朋友，通常没有任何政治企图或私心。他只是在寻求欢笑和人际连接，而不是个人利益。文章指出，凯文虽然希望被人喜欢，但迈克尔对被人喜欢的渴望达到了一种强迫症的程度。还有德怀特、奥斯卡和安吉拉这样的角色，他们真的很需要那种高人一等的感觉。吉姆总是试图给帕姆留下好印象或逗她笑。但在所有的角色中，凯文真的只是想活在当下。
Collider also points out that when Kevin accidentally found out that Oscar was having an affair with Angela's husband, he is the one who is able to keep the secret. He kept it so good. So good, he kept that secret. And that if he does make a crass joke, it's never to be mean or cruel. and that in fact it really causes him pain to hurt anyone. And I wanted to point out one of my other favorite Kevin moments that I think really speaks to this humanizing piece of him that Brian Baumgartner played so well. And it's that moment in chair model when he gets our parking spaces back. And he has that talking head?
Collider also points out that when Kevin accidentally found out that Oscar was having an affair with Angela's husband, he is the one who is able to keep the secret. He kept it so good. So good, he kept that secret. And that if he does make a crass joke, it's never to be mean or cruel. and that in fact it really causes him pain to hurt anyone. And I wanted to point out one of my other favorite Kevin moments that I think really speaks to this humanizing piece of him that Brian Baumgartner played so well. And it's that moment in chair model when he gets our parking spaces back. And he has that talking head?|||Collider 还指出，当凯文无意中发现奥斯卡与安吉拉的丈夫有染时，他是那个能够保守秘密的人。他保密得太好了。太好了，他把这个秘密守得死死的。而且如果他讲了什么粗俗的笑话，也绝对不是出于恶意或残忍，事实上伤害任何人都会让他感到痛苦。我想指出我另一个最喜欢的凯文时刻，我认为这真正体现了他人性化的一面，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳把这一面演得太好了。那就是在《椅模》（Chair Model）那一集中，他帮我们把停车位要回来了。当时他有一个访谈独白镜头，对吧？
Yeah, where he says, it's just nice to win one. Yeah, and he has a little bit of a tear up in his eye. Yeah. So that's my deep dive into Kevin. There are so many other, like, funny one-liners that I didn't even get to. Screen Rant did a whole list of fan favorites. I can tell you some of them because they are fun. Oh, let's hear them.
Yeah, where he says, it's just nice to win one. Yeah, and he has a little bit of a tear up in his eye. Yeah. So that's my deep dive into Kevin. There are so many other, like, funny one-liners that I didn't even get to. Screen Rant did a whole list of fan favorites. I can tell you some of them because they are fun. Oh, let's hear them.|||对，他在里面说，能赢一次感觉真好。对，他眼里泛起了一点泪花。对。这就是我对凯文的深度剖析。还有很多其他的搞笑台词，我甚至都没提到。Screen Rant（银幕暴击网）列出了一整份粉丝最爱清单。我可以告诉你们其中的一部分，因为它们很有趣。哦，让我们听听。
From the incentive when he says, Me Think Why Waste Time Say Lotward when Few Word Dutrick. From the finale, well, well, well, well, well. Well, that's six wells. Yeah, I love that. From viewing party, when he says, I wanted to eat a pig in a blanket in a blanket. Then also, this one of my favorites from Christmas party when he says mini cupcakes, as in the mini version of regular cupcakes, which is already a mini version of a cake. Honestly, where does it end with you, people?
From the incentive when he says, Me Think Why Waste Time Say Lotward when Few Word Dutrick. From the finale, well, well, well, well, well. Well, that's six wells. Yeah, I love that. From viewing party, when he says, I wanted to eat a pig in a blanket in a blanket. Then also, this one of my favorites from Christmas party when he says mini cupcakes, as in the mini version of regular cupcakes, which is already a mini version of a cake. Honestly, where does it end with you, people?|||来自《刺激计划》（Incentive）一集，当他说：“Me Think Why Waste Time Say Lotward when Few Word Dutrick”（我觉着能省字就省字，少说话多做事）。来自大结局，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯，嗯。好吧，那是六个“嗯”。对，我很喜欢那个。来自《观影派对》（Viewing Party），当他说：“我想吃包在毯子里的卷饼里的猪肉（pig in a blanket in a blanket）。”还有，这是我最喜欢的来自《圣诞派对》（Christmas Party）的一句，当他说：“迷你纸杯蛋糕，也就是常规纸杯蛋糕的迷你版，而常规纸杯蛋糕本身已经是蛋糕的迷你版了。说实话，你们这帮人到底有完没完？”
I love, like, it takes a lot to piss Kevin off, I feel like, but that did it. And while the point of my deep dive was to point out the more tender and, I guess, sensitive parts of Kevin, I'm going to end with this clip. This is Kevin from PDA. I don't know if anyone else feels this way. And don't get me wrong. I love Michael and Holly. And maybe I'm being overly sensitive, but the PDA. Yes, the freaking PDA.
I love, like, it takes a lot to piss Kevin off, I feel like, but that did it. And while the point of my deep dive was to point out the more tender and, I guess, sensitive parts of Kevin, I'm going to end with this clip. This is Kevin from PDA. I don't know if anyone else feels this way. And don't get me wrong. I love Michael and Holly. And maybe I'm being overly sensitive, but the PDA. Yes, the freaking PDA.|||我喜欢这种设定——我觉得要惹恼凯文很难，但那次他真的生气了。虽然我这次深度剖析的重点是指出了凯文更温柔、我想也是更敏感的一面，但我打算用这个片段来结束。这是来自《办公室恋情（PDA）》中的凯文。我不知道别人是不是也有这种感觉。别误会我。我爱迈克尔和霍莉。也许是我太敏感了，但是那个 PDA（公共场合亲热）。对，就是那个见鬼的 PDA。
Thank you. Obviously, so happy for them both. I don't know, guys, I for one, enjoy watching them. No, stop. Just don't. Can I finish? Can I finish? Is that okay?
Thank you. Obviously, so happy for them both. I don't know, guys, I for one, enjoy watching them. No, stop. Just don't. Can I finish? Can I finish? Is that okay?|||谢谢。显然，我为他们俩感到非常高兴。我不知道，伙计们，反正我很喜欢看他们这样。不，停下。别这样。能让我说完吗？能让我说完吗？行吗？
I was saying I enjoy watching them because it makes me horny. Oh, God. It's so hard for like, can I finish? I know. Can I finish? Like, maybe he's going to say something, like, maybe sentimental or, like, I'm happy for them. Like, new love. We should let them.
I was saying I enjoy watching them because it makes me horny. Oh, God. It's so hard for like, can I finish? I know. Can I finish? Like, maybe he's going to say something, like, maybe sentimental or, like, I'm happy for them. Like, new love. We should let them.|||我是说我喜欢看他们这样，因为这让我觉得很色。哦，天哪。这太难了，比如……能让我说完吗？我知道。能让我说完吗？就像，也许他会说些什么，比如，也许是感性的，或者像，我为他们高兴。比如，初恋。我们应该让他们……
Explore this time. And then he ends with that. But it makes a morning. Oh, gosh. It is really good. Well, I love that our writers made all of our characters so layered. It was such a gift to get to play characters like this on a sitcom. Really?
Explore this time. And then he ends with that. But it makes a morning. Oh, gosh. It is really good. Well, I love that our writers made all of our characters so layered. It was such a gift to get to play characters like this on a sitcom. Really?|||……在这个时期好好探索。然后他以这句话结尾。但这让我觉得很色（原话horny口误说成morning，谐音梗）。哦，天哪。这真的很搞笑。嗯，我很高兴我们的编剧把我们所有的角色都塑造得如此有层次感。能在情景喜剧中饰演这样的角色真是一份厚礼。真的吗？
Yeah. They were always willing to give us things that would surprise the audience to play. And us. And us. Yeah. All right, Angela, I'm handing it over to you. I think you have a very fun deep dive area of interest. I do.
Yeah. They were always willing to give us things that would surprise the audience to play. And us. And us. Yeah. All right, Angela, I'm handing it over to you. I think you have a very fun deep dive area of interest. I do.|||对。他们总是愿意给我们一些能让观众感到惊讶的剧情去演。还有我们。还有我们。对。好了，安吉拉，我把接力棒交给你了。我觉得你有一个非常有趣的感兴趣的深度剖析领域。我的确有。
My deep dive area of interest is so funny. It's such a long title. Was inspired by this fan question sent in from Alexander G. In Houston, Texas. Alexander wrote and said, I have heard a lot of theories that Kevin is secretly a genius and is committing fraud with company money. There have been some hints in some episodes. like in season three, when Martin Nash explains why he went to prison, I want to know y'all's thoughts on this theory.
My deep dive area of interest is so funny. It's such a long title. Was inspired by this fan question sent in from Alexander G. In Houston, Texas. Alexander wrote and said, I have heard a lot of theories that Kevin is secretly a genius and is committing fraud with company money. There have been some hints in some episodes. like in season three, when Martin Nash explains why he went to prison, I want to know y'all's thoughts on this theory.|||我感兴趣的深度剖析领域太搞笑了。标题好长。灵感来自德克萨斯州休斯敦的亚历山大·G（Alexander G）发来的这个粉丝提问。亚历山大写道：我听到过很多理论，说凯文其实是个天才，并且在用公司的钱进行欺诈。在某些剧集里有一些暗示，比如在第三季中，马丁·纳什（Martin Nash）解释他为什么入狱时，我想知道大家对这个理论有什么看法。
Well, Alexander, there are lots of, lots of fan theories about this, and it sent me down a rabbit hole. I found so many moments on the show that support the secret genius theory. So my title is Kevin Malone, dot, dot, dot, dot, secret genius. Not dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, no, because just three dots. Just three dots. Okay. Which, by the way, my kids have told me, my teenagers, that doing the dot, dot, dot is a very old person thing. I've heard any punctuation in a text is like an old person thing.
Well, Alexander, there are lots of, lots of fan theories about this, and it sent me down a rabbit hole. I found so many moments on the show that support the secret genius theory. So my title is Kevin Malone, dot, dot, dot, dot, secret genius. Not dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, no, because just three dots. Just three dots. Which, by the way, my kids have told me, my teenagers, that doing the dot, dot, dot is a very old person thing. I've heard any punctuation in a text is like an old person thing.|||嗯，亚历山大，关于这一点有很多很多的粉丝理论，这让我陷入了一个疯狂的研究迷宫。我在剧中找到了太多支持“秘密天才论”的瞬间。所以我的标题是：凯文·马隆，点，点，点，点，秘密天才。不是点，点，点，点，点，点，不，因为只有三个点。只有三个点。顺便说一句，我的孩子们曾告诉我，我的青少年时期的孩子们说，打点点点是非常老年人的行为。我听说短信里的任何标点符号都像是老年人的行为。
Any capitalization, any periods. I can't live in that world where we aren't punctuating this. So sorry. We were like, what are you talking about? And then they went through our family text thread. And the one that really made us all laugh is that Josh texted the first. family text thread and said, coming home from the gym, dot, dot, dot, dot. And the kids were like, dot, dot, dot, dot, what? Wait, he didn't put anything after dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. Coming home from the gym,
Any capitalization, any periods. I can't live in that world where we aren't punctuating this. So sorry. We were like, what are you talking about? And then they went through our family text thread. And the one that really made us all laugh is that Josh texted the first. family text thread and said, coming home from the gym, dot, dot, dot, dot. And the kids were like, dot, dot, dot, dot, what? Wait, he didn't put anything after dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. Coming home from the gym,|||任何大写字母，任何句号。我无法生活在一个我们不使用标点符号的世界里。实在抱歉。当时我们想：你们在说什么呢？然后他们翻看了我们家族的群聊短信。其中一条真的让我们所有人都笑喷了，那就是乔希在家族群聊的最初发了一条短信说：刚从健身房回家，点，点，点，点。然后孩子们说：点，点，点，点，什么？等等，他在点点点点点后面什么也没加。刚从健身房回家，
dot, dot, dot, dot. And he was like, I just wanted you guys to know I'm coming home from the gym. I add a lot of dot dot dot dots in my text messages to sort of help you read it the way I would want you to. For me, it's like I'm moving thoughts here. Yeah, I know. I'm kind of. I'm like, I feel like as an actor, I appreciate a lot of punctuation because it helps me get a feel for the dialogue. And on the office, there were a lot of dot, dot, dots in our scripts. I know. They wanted to like suggest pauses and transitions from one thought to another. So I guess I love a lot of punctuation.
dot, dot, dot, dot. And he was like, I just wanted you guys to know I'm coming home from the gym. I add a lot of dot dot dot dots in my text messages to sort of help you read it the way I would want you to. For me, it's like I'm moving thoughts here. Yeah, I know. I'm kind of. I'm like, I feel like as an actor, I appreciate a lot of punctuation because it helps me get a feel for the dialogue. And on the office, there were a lot of dot, dot, dots in our scripts. I know. They wanted to like suggest pauses and transitions from one thought to another. So I guess I love a lot of punctuation.|||点，点，点，点。然后他说：我只是想让你们知道我要从健身房回家了。我在短信里加了很多点点点，是为了帮助你按照我希望的方式去阅读它。对我来说，这就像是我在转换思路。是的，我知道。我有种……我觉得作为一名演员，我很欣赏大量的标点符号，因为这有助于我感受对话的语感。在《办公室》里，我们的剧本里有很多点点点。我知道。他们想借此暗示停顿以及从一个想法到另一个想法的过渡。所以我想我非常喜欢各种标点符号。
Well, it means you're old when you text. Oh. Also, my kid said that Josh is like, he's the king of dot, dot, dot, dot, but I'm the queen of emojis. Oh, yeah. Thumbs up. Heart. Lady dancing. Yeah, emojis mean you're old too, right?
Well, means you're old when you text. Oh. Also, my kid said that Josh is like, he's the king of dot, dot, dot, dot, but I'm the queen of emojis. Oh, yeah. Thumbs up. Heart. Lady dancing. Yeah, emojis mean you're old too, right?|||好吧，发短信带标点说明你老了。哦。还有，我的孩子说乔希简直是“点点点点之王”，而我是“表情符号女王”。哦，是的。竖大拇指。爱心。跳舞的女人。对，用表情符号也说明你老了，对吧？
No. The Young and Stone emoji? I don't know. I don't know either. Okay. We don't know because we're old. We wouldn't know. Okay.
No. The Young and Stone emoji? I don't know. I don't know either. Okay. We don't know because we're old. We wouldn't know. Okay.|||不对。年轻人专属表情符号？我不知道。我也不知道。好吧。我们不知道是因为我们老了。我们不会知道的。好吧。
Sorry. Where was I? Oh, Kevin Malone. Dot, dot, dot, secret genius. Yes. Please go on. Let's start with something that Jenna, you and Kevin have in common. What?
Sorry. Where was I? Oh, Kevin Malone. Dot, dot, dot, secret genius. Yes. Please go on. Let's start with something that Jenna, you and Kevin have in common. What?|||抱歉。我刚才讲到哪儿了？哦，凯文·马隆。点，点，点，秘密天才。是的。请继续。让我们从珍娜你和凯文共同的一个特点开始。什么？
You're both fantastic poker players. Oh, yes. Yes. We learn about Kevin's poker playing in Casino Night, season two. Here's the moment I'm talking about. You referred to it. Let's hear this Kevin Talking Head. I won the 2002-2-2500 No Limit, Deuce to Seven draw tournament at the World Series of Poker in Vegas. So yeah, I'm pretty good at poker. Yeah. A little bit of a flex there. And, you know, after watching that Kevin Talking Head, I thought, what makes a good poker player? What do they all have in common? Here's what the internet has to say, folks. Okay. They are disciplined, patient, confident, have a mental toughness and a strong understanding of game theory and the math behind poker strategy. They can manage their bankroll effectively and have strong analytical skills, decision making, plus the ability to read opponents, adapt to different playing styles, and know how to bluff and to maintain emotional control. Wow.
You're both fantastic poker players. Oh, yes. Yes. We learn about Kevin's poker playing in Casino Night, season two. Here's the moment I'm talking about. You referred to it. Let's hear this Kevin Talking Head. I won the 2002-2-2500 No Limit, Deuce to Seven draw tournament at the World Series of Poker in Vegas. So yeah, I'm pretty good at poker. Yeah. A little bit of a flex there. And, you know, after watching that Kevin Talking Head, I thought, what makes a good poker player? What do they all have in common? Here's what the internet has to say, folks. Okay. They are disciplined, patient, confident, have a mental toughness and a strong understanding of game theory and the math behind poker strategy. They can manage their bankroll effectively and have strong analytical skills, decision making, plus the ability to read opponents, adapt to different playing styles, and know how to bluff and to maintain emotional control. Wow.|||你们俩都是出色的扑克玩家。哦，是的。是的。我们在第二季的《赌场之夜》中了解到凯文会打扑克。这就是我所说的那个时刻。你提到过它。让我们听听这段凯文的独白访谈。我赢得了 2002 年拉斯维加斯世界扑克大赛 2500 美元无限注七张牌换牌锦标赛的冠军。所以，是的，我很擅长打扑克。是的。这里有点在炫耀的意思。而且，你知道的，看完那个凯文的独白后，我想，是什么造就了一个优秀的扑克玩家？他们有什么共同点？各位，以下是互联网上的说法。好的。他们自律、有耐心、自信，拥有强大的心理素质，对博弈论以及扑克策略背后的数学原理有深刻的理解。他们能有效地管理自己的资金库，具备强大的分析能力、决策能力，并且能够洞察对手、适应不同的打法，还懂得如何诈唬（bluff）并保持情绪控制。哇。
Wowzers. It's a lot. It's a lot, lady. You and Kevin can do all that. I don't know if I can do all that all the time. Well, I think this definitely supports is Kevin a secret genius? He's a lot smarter than he lets on, and there are several more moments that show this. In season three in the episode The Convict, we learned that Martin was in prison for insider trading.
Wowzers. It's a lot. It's a lot, lady. You and Kevin can do all that. I don't know if I can do all that all the time. Well, I think this definitely supports is Kevin a secret genius? He's a lot smarter than he lets on, and there are several more moments that show this. In season three in the episode The Convict, we learned that Martin was in prison for insider trading.|||哇塞。内容真多。内容真多啊，女士。你和凯文能做到这一切。我不知道我是不是能一直做到所有这些。嗯，我认为这绝对支持了“凯文是秘密天才吗？”这一假说。他比表面上看起来要聪明得多，还有好几个瞬间证明了这一点。在第三季的《囚犯》一集中，我们了解到马丁因内幕交易而入狱。
Kevin has a talking head where he says, I had Martin explained to me three times what he got arrested for because it sounds an awful lot like what I do here every day. What's Kevin been doing? Has he been trading Dundermifflin stock or other securities? I mean, what's happening? Maybe some embezzlement? Maybe. Then there's the time Kevin outplays Andy and Daryl in the game Dallas in the garage sale episode. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Kevin has a talking head where he says, I had Martin explained to me three times what he got arrested for because it sounds an awful lot like what I do here every day. What's Kevin been doing? Has he been trading Dundermifflin stock or other securities? I mean, what's happening? Maybe some embezzlement? Maybe. Then there's the time Kevin outplays Andy and Daryl in the game Dallas in the garage sale episode. Oh, yeah. Yeah.|||凯文有一段独白说：我让马丁给我解释了三倍他因为什么被捕，因为这听起来和我在这里每天做的事太像了。凯文一直在做什么？他一直在交易邓德米夫林（Dundermifflin）的股票或其他证券吗？我是说，到底怎么回事？也许有些挪用公款？也许吧。还有一次是在《车库大甩卖》那一集中，凯文在玩《达拉斯》（Dallas）桌游时智胜了安迪和达里尔。哦，是的。对。
Let's hear that. Well, there's no instructions. It's Dallas. Game, we can figure it out. Yeah, I'm pretty good at poor games. Well, shall we make it a little interesting? Sure. Hmm, I'm going to play me a little old blackmail card.
Let's hear that. Well, there's no instructions. It's Dallas. Game, we can figure it out. Yeah, I'm pretty good at poor games. Well, shall we make it a little interesting? Sure. Hmm, I'm going to play me a little old blackmail card.|||听听这个。嗯，没有说明书。这是《达拉斯》。游戏嘛，我们可以自己琢磨出来。是的，我很擅长劣质游戏（注：poor games，疑为主播口误或双关）。那么，我们要不要让它变得有趣一点？当然。嗯，我要打出一张小小的老式勒索牌。
Nice. And call a proxy meeting and take control of Ewing oil once and for all. No, you can't do that. You can't play a blackmail card and call a proxy meeting in the same turn. Why not? Seems to me we're just making up rules because somebody forgot to staple the rulebook
Nice. And call a proxy meeting and take control of Ewing oil once and for all. No, you can't do that. You can't play a blackmail card and call a proxy meeting in the same turn. Why not? Seems to me we're just making up rules because somebody forgot to staple the rulebook|||干得好。并召开代理人会议，一劳永逸地夺取尤因石油公司（Ewing Oil）的控制权。不，你不能这么做。你不能在同一个回合里既打出勒索牌又召开代理人会议。为什么不能？在我看来，我们只是在胡编乱造规则，因为有人忘了解把规则手册……
to the inside of the game, like a normal human being. And I'm going to play this here, share the wealth card, which entitles me to half of both of you all's money. So if you don't mind. No, this card is from the wrong game. This is from the game of life. It was in the box.
to the inside of the game, like a normal human being. And I'm going to play this here, share the wealth card, which entitles me to half of both of you all's money. So if you don't mind. No, this card is from the wrong game. This is from the game of life. It was in the box.|||……像个正常人一样订在游戏盒内侧。我要在这里打出这张“分享财富”卡，它让我有权获得你们俩一半的钱。所以如果你们不介意的话。不，这张牌拿错游戏了。这是《人生游戏》（The Game of Life）里的。它怎么会在盒子里。
Well played. We must honorably adhere to the rules that we are making up on the spot. No, but that's not fair. Well, that's Dallas. Dallas, indeed. Okay, guys, it's my turn. You can't go. You're dead. I shot you five moves ago. Yeah, I told you you can't shoot people.
Well played. We must honorably adhere to the rules that we are making up on the spot. No, but that's not fair. Well, that's Dallas. Dallas, indeed. Okay, guys, it's my turn. You can't go. You're dead. I shot you five moves ago. Yeah, I told you you can't shoot people.|||玩得漂亮。我们必须光荣地遵守我们当场编造的规则。不，但这不公平。嗯，这就是《达拉斯》。确实是《达拉斯》。好了，伙计们，轮到我了。你不能走。你已经死了。我在五步之前就把你枪毙了。对，我告诉过你不能朝人开枪。
I told you we're way past rules. We have been for some time now. I start having rules now. Everything we built collapses. Well, this is stupid. And I want my money. back. Where's the money? Yeah, where is it?
I told you we're way past rules. We have been for some time now. I start having rules now. Everything we built collapses. Well, this is stupid. And I want my money. back. Where's the money? Yeah, where is it?|||我告诉过你，我们早就过了讲规则的阶段了。我们已经这样好一阵子了。我现在要是开始讲规则，我们建立的一切都会崩溃。好吧，这太蠢了。而且我要把我的钱拿回来。钱在哪里？对，钱在哪儿？
Okay, you know what? I am never, ever playing games with you two again. And that is Dallas. Uh-huh, do you remember? So what he does is he distracts them and he takes
Okay, you know what? I am never, ever playing games with you two again. And that is Dallas. Uh-huh, do you remember? So what he does is he distracts them and he takes|||好吧，你知道吗？我再也不、再也不跟你们两个玩游戏了。这就是《达拉斯》。嗯哼，你们还记得吗？所以他做的是，他分散他们的注意力，然后拿走了……
the money, all their money, out of the pot. Wow. Yeah, what did he do in that moment, you guys? He adapted to a different playing style. He knew. How to Bluff. He maintained emotional control, and he got all their money. Wow. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Yep. And a special shout out to Sam for helping me put all those clips together. Because it's throughout the episode. Yes. But yeah, that's how you play Dallas. Then in the accounting web episodes, it's Kevin who finds Angel's accounting error. And it's also revealed that Kevin has an IQ of over 100. Which isn't that high. Which isn't that high, but okay. Okay. Not genius level. I thought, well.
the money, all their money, out of the pot. Wow. Yeah, what did he do in that moment, you guys? He adapted to a different playing style. He knew. How to Bluff. He maintained emotional control, and he got all their money. Wow. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Yep. And a special shout out to Sam for helping me put all those clips together. Because it's throughout the episode. Yes. But yeah, that's how you play Dallas. Then in the accounting web episodes, it's Kevin who finds Angel's accounting error. And it's also revealed that Kevin has an IQ of over 100. Which isn't that high. Which isn't that high, but okay. Okay. Not genius level. I thought, well.|||……彩池里的钱，他们所有的钱。哇。是的，大家，他在那一刻做了什么？他适应了不同的打法。他懂得如何诈唬。他保持了情绪控制，并且拿走了他们所有的钱。哇。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。是的。特别鸣谢萨姆帮我把所有这些片段剪辑到一起。因为这贯穿了整集。是的。但没错，这就是玩《达拉斯》的方式。然后，在会计网络剧集里，是凯文发现了安吉拉的会计错误。并且还透露凯文的智商超过 100。这其实没那么高。这其实没那么高，不过好吧。好吧。还达不到天才水平。我想，好吧。
In sort of being a secret genius. Maybe secret genius Kevin level. What does that mean? I don't know. I don't know. I'm just trying to support my deep dive. And in the trivia episode in season eight, it is Kevin who has the winning answers that lead his team, the Einstein's to victory. Yes.
In sort of being a secret genius. Maybe secret genius Kevin level. What does that mean? I don't know. I don't know. I'm just trying to support my deep dive. And in the trivia episode in season eight, it is Kevin who has the winning answers that lead his team, the Einstein's to victory. Yes.|||就某种意义上的秘密天才而言。也许是“秘密天才凯文级别”。那是什么意思？我不知道。我也不知道。我只是在试图支撑我的深度剖析。在第八季的益智问答那一集中，正是凯文给出了制胜答案，带领他的团队“爱因斯坦队”走向了胜利。是的。
Then he has an interesting talking head afterwards. Let's hear it. I know it's easy to say tonight was just a fluke. And maybe it was. But here's a piece of trivia. A fluke is one of the most common fish in the sea. So if you go fishing for a fluke, chances are he just might catch one. Oh, and that's a great talking head.
Then he has an interesting talking head afterwards. Let's hear it. I know it's easy to say tonight was just a fluke. And maybe it was. But here's a piece of trivia. A fluke is one of the most common fish in the sea. So if you go fishing for a fluke, chances are he just might catch one. Oh, and that's a great talking head.|||随后他发表了一段有趣的独白。我们来听听。我知道很容易说今晚只是侥幸。也许吧。但这里有一个冷知识。比目鱼（fluke）是海中最常见的鱼类之一。所以如果你去钓比目鱼，你很有可能真的能钓到一条。哦，那真是一段精彩的独白。
And guess what? Fluke fish are very common. According to the internet, fluke are abundant in coastal waters from the Gulf of Maine to Florida, especially in the waters from North Carolina to Massachusetts. Kevin's right. He knows his fish. He does. He knows more than we know that he knows.
And guess what? Fluke fish are very common. According to the internet, fluke are abundant in coastal waters from the Gulf of Maine to Florida, especially in the waters from North Carolina to Massachusetts. Kevin's right. He knows his fish. He does. He knows more than we know that he knows.|||你们猜怎么着？比目鱼非常常见。根据互联网的说法，从缅因湾到佛罗里达州的沿海水域，到处都是比目鱼，尤其是从北卡罗来纳州到马萨诸塞州的水域。凯文是对的。他很懂鱼。他确实懂。他知道的比我们以为他知道的要多得多。
Secret genius. Dot, dot, dot, dot. And let's not forget this moment in work bus. Jim says, let's go driver, Laverne packs up the pie wagon at five. And then Kevin immediately starts doing this math. He says, at five, that's only 20 minutes from now. The pie shop is 13 miles away. So at 55 miles an hour, that gives us just five minutes to spare.
Secret genius. Dot, dot, dot, dot. And let's not forget this moment in work bus. Jim says, let's go driver, Laverne packs up the pie wagon at five. And then Kevin immediately starts doing this math. He says, at five, that's only 20 minutes from now. The pie shop is 13 miles away. So at 55 miles an hour, that gives us just five minutes to spare.|||秘密天才。点，点，点，点。我们别忘了《工作大巴》（Work Bus）里的这个瞬间。吉姆说：开车吧司机，拉韦恩（Laverne）五点钟就要收摊派车了。然后凯文立刻开始算起了数学。他说：五点钟，离现在只有 20 分钟了。派店有 13 英里远。所以以每小时 55 英里的速度行驶，我们只剩下五分钟的富余时间。
Angela says, so wait, when pies are involved, you can suddenly do math. in your head. And Oscar says, hold on, Kevin. How much is 19,154 pies divided by 61 pies? Without missing a beat, Kevin says 314 pies. Lastly, is the thing we're going to talk about more in detail with Brian. But Kevin is also a musical genius because he is both the lead singer and drummer, which are notoriously difficult roles to perform at the same time.
Angela says, so wait, when pies are involved, you can suddenly do math. in your head. And Oscar says, hold on, Kevin. How much is 19,154 pies divided by 61 pies? Without missing a beat, Kevin says 314 pies. Lastly, is the thing we're going to talk about more in detail with Brian. But Kevin is also a musical genius because he is both the lead singer and drummer, which are notoriously difficult roles to perform at the same time.|||安吉拉说：等等，只要一扯到派，你突然就能在脑子里算数学了。奥斯卡说：等等，凯文。19,154 个派除以 61 个派等于多少？凯文不假思索地回答说：314 个派。最后，是我们接下来要和布莱恩更详细探讨的事情。但凯文也是一个音乐天才，因为他既是主唱又是鼓手，众所周知，这两个角色要同时扮演是非常困难的。
I want to add that a lot of drummers are really good. mathematicians. My son is a drummer, and this is something that I have found to be true with other drummers and other drumming musicians. I don't know if it is something about rhythm or beat or whatever it is or keeping different rhythms and different beats with different appendages. Yeah. But there's like a math through line there. That's really interesting. Well, Alexander, I wanted to thank you for writing in. I do think Kevin is a secret genius, and he's very good at reading people and ultimately getting what he wants. And as for the second part of your question, did he steal money from Dunder Mifflin over the years?
I want to add that a lot of drummers are really good. mathematicians. My son is a drummer, and this is something that I have found to be true with other drummers and other drumming musicians. I don't know if it is something about rhythm or beat or whatever it is or keeping different rhythms and different beats with different appendages. Yeah. But there's like a math through line there. That's really interesting. Well, Alexander, I wanted to thank you for writing in. I do think Kevin is a secret genius, and he's very good at reading people and ultimately getting what he wants. And as for the second part of your question, did he steal money from Dunder Mifflin over the years?|||我想补充一点，很多鼓手其实都是优秀的数学家。我儿子是个鼓手，这是我在其他鼓手和其他打击乐音乐家身上发现的一个事实。我不知道这是否与节奏、节拍或是用不同的肢体部位维持不同的节奏和拍子有关。是的。但那里确实存在一条数学的暗线。这真的很有趣。好吧，亚历山大，我想谢谢你写信来。我确实认为凯文是一个秘密天才，他非常擅长揣摩人心，并最终得到他想要的东西。至于你问题的第二部分，多年来他是否从邓德米夫林偷过钱？
Did he commit fraud? Well, you know, I think he very well could have. There are several times we learned that he is using the company petty cash for gambling. And Kevin is definitely a little sneaky. I think that with almost 100% certainty, we could confirm that he has used the company money for personal reasons. Yes. Yes, I mean, for sure. For sure.
Did he commit fraud? Well, you know, I think he very well could have. There are several times we learned that he is using the company petty cash for gambling. And Kevin is definitely a little sneaky. I think that with almost 100% certainty, we could confirm that he has used the company money for personal reasons. Yes. Yes, I mean, for sure. For sure.|||他有没有进行欺诈？嗯，你知道的，我认为他很有可能做过。有好几次我们了解到他在用公司的零用钱赌博。而且凯文确实有点鬼祟。我认为我们几乎可以百分之百确定，他曾为了个人原因动用过公司的资金。是的。是的，我的意思是，肯定的。肯定的。
Well, Angela, I loved that. Why don't we go to break? And when we come back, we will have Brian Baumgartner in studio to talk all about Kevin Malone. I love it. Brian, thank you for joining us in our episode all about Kevin Malone. We've got four Kevin Malone-centered questions for you. Okay. Are you ready?
Well, Angela, I loved that. Why don't we go to break? And when we come back, we will have Brian Baumgartner in studio to talk all about Kevin Malone. I love it. Brian, thank you for joining us in our episode all about Kevin Malone. We've got four Kevin Malone-centered questions for you. Okay. Are you ready?|||安吉拉，我太喜欢这个了。我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来后，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳将作客录音室，和我们畅聊关于凯文·马隆的一切。太棒了。布莱恩，谢谢你加入我们这期专属于凯文·马隆的节目。我们为你准备了四个以凯文·马隆为核心的问题。好的。你准备好了吗？
Is this going to be the greatest episode in the history of this show? Yeah, it is. We're doing an all about for each character. and this is your chance to win. Oh, okay. I'm ready. Question number one. Question one.
Is this going to be the greatest episode in the history of this show? Yeah, it is. We're doing an all about for each character. and this is your chance to win. Oh, okay. I'm ready. Question number one. Question one.|||这会是本节目历史上最棒的一集吗？是的，绝对是。我们正在为每个角色做一个专题节目，而这是你获胜的机会。哦，好吧。我准备好了。第一个问题。问题一。
Did you ever create a backstory for the character of Kevin? And if so, can you share some details of that backstory? Wow. Really good question. Much more in depth than I thought it was going to be. Thank you for that. I'm taking you back to theater school here, Brian. Well, here's what I remember.
Did you ever create a backstory for the character of Kevin? And if so, can you share some details of that backstory? Wow. Really good question. Much more in depth than I thought it was going to be. Thank you for that. I'm taking you back to theater school here, Brian. Well, here's what I remember.|||你曾为凯文这个角色创作过背景故事吗？如果有的话，能分享一下那个背景故事的一些细节吗？哇。真的很好的问题。比我想象的要深入得多。谢谢你的提问。我这是把你带回了戏剧学校啊，布莱恩。嗯，这是我所记得的。
And it comes with a joke. The breakdowns, the casting listing for Kevin. Kevin Malone, who of course was based on Keith Bishop in the British version of the office, the casting notice was as follows. The only spectacular thing about Kevin is that he is spectacularly unspectacular. Now, the joke in that exists with my manager, who I'm still with, to this day, is like calling the casting director, Alison Jones and Phyllis at the time and being like, Oh, do I have an unspectacular guy for you?
And it comes with a joke. The breakdowns, the casting listing for Kevin. Kevin Malone, who of course was based on Keith Bishop in the British version of the office, the casting notice was as follows. The only spectacular thing about Kevin is that he is spectacularly unspectacular. Now, the joke in that exists with my manager, who I'm still with, to this day, is like calling the casting director, Alison Jones and Phyllis at the time and being like, Oh, do I have an unspectacular guy for you?|||而且这里面还有一个笑话。关于凯文的演员挑选通告（breakdowns）。凯文·马隆，当然是以英国版《办公室》中的基思·毕夏普（Keith Bishop）为原型的，选角通知如下：凯文唯一引人注目（spectacular）的地方在于他极其平庸（unspectacular）。而其中包含的笑话在于，我和至今仍合作的经纪人一起，给当时的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）和菲利斯打电话说：哦，我这儿有个平庸至极的家伙要推荐给你们！
This guy is so unspectacular. You know, it's tough because I think that for me, and at least when we were brought in, that's where it started. So I felt like the backstory in a way existed, i.e. vis-a-vis Keith. It was very important to me that his name was Malone. I was asked that. That was my choice because I knew that I knew that there were a lot of Irish people in Scranton. Like they have the second largest St. Patrick's Day parade. Like this is a big deal.
This guy is so unspectacular. You know, it's tough because I think that for me, and at least when we were brought in, that's where it started. So I felt like the backstory in a way existed, i.e. vis-a-vis Keith. It was very important to me that his name was Malone. I was asked that. That was my choice because I knew that I knew that there were a lot of Irish people in Scranton. Like they have the second largest St. Patrick's Day parade. Like this is a big deal.|||这家伙平庸得无以复加。你知道的，这很难，因为我认为对我和我们当时被招募进组的时候来说，一切就是从这里开始的。所以我感觉背景故事在某种程度上是存在的，即对照基思（Keith）。对我来说，他的名字叫马隆非常重要。有人问过我。那是我的选择，因为我知道斯克兰顿有很多爱尔兰人。比如他们有规模第二大的圣帕特里克节游行。这可是一件大事。
And so I thought that I thought that that aspect of it was fun. I helped to identify fairly early on. So I think the answer to your question is probably no. but I had some ideas about him and who he was and pitched Greg on pretty early. Like I liked the idea of the relationship with someone who had a kid and it was like, Stacey, before we sort of knew who he was. Like as you started to find out those details,
And so I thought that I thought that aspect of it was fun. I helped to identify fairly early on. So I think the answer to your question is probably no. but I had some ideas about him and who he was and pitched Greg on pretty early. Like I liked the idea of the relationship with someone who had a kid and it was like, Stacey, before we sort of knew who he was. Like as you started to find out those details,|||所以我觉得那方面的设定很有趣。我挺早就协助确定了这一点。所以我认为你问题的答案大概是否定的。但我确实有一些关于他以及他是谁的想法，并且很早就向格雷格（Greg）提出了构想。比如我喜欢这样一种构思：他和某个有孩子的人建立恋爱关系，也就是斯黛西，在我们大致了解他是谁之前。就像当你开始发现这些细节时……
a lot of those that I was pitched, but I didn't write a book like I know you did. No, I didn't write a book. Well, for example, where did the idea come from for him to be in a band or for him to be good at poker? Were these, I feel like the poker thing had to be from you. Pitches? Yeah, so I think that the poker thing was a pitch from me. My recollection of that was that whole idea came out of us, one, playing poker like some of the people on the show.
a lot of those that I was pitched, but I didn't write a book like I know you did. No, I didn't write a book. Well, for example, where did the idea come from for him to be in a band or for him to be good at poker? Were these, I feel like the poker thing had to be from you. Pitches? Yeah, so I think that the poker thing was a pitch from me. My recollection of that was that whole idea came out of us, one, playing poker like some of the people on the show.|||……很多都是我提出来的，但我可没写过书，我知道你写了。不，我没写书。好吧，比如说，他加入乐队或者他擅长打扑克的想法是从哪里来的？这些是……我感觉打扑克的设定一定是你提出来的。创意提案？对，所以我觉得打扑克的点子是我提的。我的记忆是，整个点子源于我们一、像剧中的一些人一样在打扑克。
that that idea came out of it. I think the whole World Series of poker was because I was good at it. Now, if you remember, the basketball thing was that was discovered by Greg then. I mean, that was. On the day, you were just messing around. On the week. I mean, it was the week. I mean, now if you, what I joke about is if you give, we were boys.
that that idea came out of it. I think the whole World Series of poker was because I was good at it. Now, if you remember, the basketball thing was that was discovered by Greg then. I mean, that was. On the day, you were just messing around. On the week. I mean, it was the week. I mean, now if you, what I joke about is if you give, we were boys.|||这个点子就是这么来的。我觉得整个世界扑克大赛的设定是因为我很擅长它。现在，如果你们还记得的话，打篮球那件事是格雷格后来发现的。我的意思是，那是……当天的拍摄中，你们只是在瞎胡闹。在那一周里。我的意思是，那是那一周里。我的意思是，现在如果你……我开玩笑说的是，如果你给……我们当时还是大男孩。
I mean, Krasinski and I, like, we were children still. And like if you have a ball and a hoop in a gym, as soon as the teacher is not looking, like you're shooting. Like you're dribbling and making the ADs crazy because of the bouncing ball and the sound that that has. But that's just what we did. And so- I just remember them feeding you one, Brian, and you made it. And then they fed it to again and you made it. And then you made it.
I mean, Krasinski and I, like, we were children still. And like if you have a ball and a hoop in a gym, as soon as the teacher is not looking, like you're shooting. Like you're dribbling and making the ADs crazy because of the bouncing ball and the sound that that has. But that's just what we did. And so- I just remember them feeding you one, Brian, and you made it. And then they fed it to again and you made it. And then you made it.|||我是说，我和卡辛斯基（Krasinski）就像还是小孩子一样。如果你在体育馆里放一个球和一个篮框，只要老师一不注意，你就会开始投篮。就像你在运球，因为弹跳的球和它发出的声音把助理导演（AD）们急疯了。但这就是我们当时做的事。所以——我只记得他们给你传了一个球，布莱恩，然后你投中了。然后他们又传给你，你又投中了。然后你又投中了。
And then everyone just stopped talking and you were just swishing them. Yeah. I mean, I think that that the moment of filming, which that, by the way, that was one take two. I never really think about that, but that was one take two. That that came out of them watching. And it's funny now. Coopus claims it's his idea. Greg claims it's his idea.
And then everyone just stopped talking and you were just swishing them. Yeah. I mean, I think that that the moment of filming, which that, by the way, that was one take two. I never really think about that, but that was one take two. That that came out of them watching. And it's funny now. Coopus claims it's his idea. Greg claims it's his idea.|||然后所有人都停止了交谈，而你一直在空心入网。是的。我的意思是，我认为拍摄那个时刻——顺便说一句，那是第二个镜头一条过（one take two）。我从没怎么想过那件事，但那是第二个镜头一条过——那是他们看着产生的。现在回想起来挺有意思的。库珀斯（Coopus，指Kent Zbornak或编剧Paul Lieberstein等）声称那是他的主意。格雷格声称那是他的主意。
Correll claims it was his idea, like to turn the cameras on me shooting as everybody's walking off. It was sort of prearranged because someone definitely said, like, go over there and shoot and we'll bring the cameras over to you. But then it went on and on. Well, my memory was you were shooting, like you said, between takes. Yes. And you kept making them. Yes. And then we all were, like, kind of whispering to Matt and Randall, like, you guys should film Brian when he's doing this because he's making them all.
Correll claims it was his idea, like to turn the cameras on me shooting as everybody's walking off. It was sort of prearranged because someone definitely said, like, go over there and shoot and we'll bring the cameras over to you. But then it went on and on. Well, my memory was you were shooting, like you said, between takes. Yes. And you kept making them. Yes. And then we all were, like, kind of whispering to Matt and Randall, like, you guys should film Brian when he's doing this because he's making them all.|||卡雷尔（Steve Carell）声称那是他的主意，比如在大家离场时把摄像机转过来拍我投篮。这有点像是事先安排好的，因为肯定有人说过类似“去那边投篮，我们会把摄像机带过去”这样的话。但后来就没完没了了。嗯，我的记忆是，正如你所说，你是在两次拍摄的间隙投篮。是的。而且你一直投进。是的。然后我们所有人都私下对马特（Matt）和兰德尔（Randall）嘀咕说，你们应该把布莱恩做这件事的时候拍下来，因为他全都能投进。
See, Kenzie takes credit for it, too. See, like everyone. No, no, no. No, no. I'm not taking credit. I just remember there was a little bit of a buzz on set. Like, is someone getting this? Is someone getting this?
See, Kenzie takes credit for it, too. See, like everyone. No, no, no. No, no. I'm not taking credit. I just remember there was a little bit of a buzz on set. Like, is someone getting this? Is someone getting this?|||你看，金斯利（Kinsey）也把这功劳揽到自己身上了。看吧，每个人都这样。不，不，不。不，不。我没有居功。我只记得当时片场有点小轰动。大家都在想：有人在拍这个吗？有人在拍这个吗？
Yes. No, that's for that. And then it came down to me and I said, look. Randall, get your ass over there and film this. Yeah. So, I mean, I think the thing that was really important to me was the idea that Kevin was not a Kevin. Let me explain that. That made no sense.
Yes. No, that's for that. And then it came down to me and I said, look. Randall, get your ass over there and film this. Yeah. So, I mean, I think the thing that was really important to me was the idea that Kevin was not a Kevin. Let me explain that. That made no sense.|||是的。不，那是为了那件事。然后轮到我时我说，听着。兰德尔，把你的屁股挪到那边去，把这个拍下来。是的。所以，我的意思是，我认为对我很重要的一点是，凯文不是一个刻板印象中的“凯文”。让我解释一下。这听起来可能没道理。
I think I know where you're going with this. The idea, if you saw in 99% of other sitcoms, a character such as Kevin, he would exist in a certain way. There would be ketchup stains on his shirt. It would be untucked. There would be slovenly, I guess, would be the word. And so early on in conversations, I don't know if this was a backstory per se, but in talking with the producers but also wardrobe,
I think I know where you're going with this. The idea, if you saw in 99% of other sitcoms, a character such as Kevin, he would exist in a certain way. There would be ketchup stains on his shirt. It would be untucked. There would be slovenly, I guess, would be the word. And so early on in conversations, I don't know if this was a backstory per se, but in talking with the producers but also wardrobe,|||我想我知道你要说什么了。这个想法是，如果你在其他 99% 的情景喜剧中看到凯文这样的角色，他会以某种特定的方式存在。他的衬衫上会有番茄酱渍。衣服会不束进裤子里。我想“邋遢”这个词会很适合他。所以在早期的对话中，我不知道这是否算背景故事本身，但在与制片人以及服装部门交流时……
I mean, even in that basketball scene you just reference, Kevin's wearing a sport coat. And all of that was very intentional by me. I was like, look, he is attempting as best he can in his dockers and his like plaid-ish, like very ordinary jackets. He's putting it together. He has his tie on. It's not loose.
I mean, even in that basketball scene you just reference, Kevin's wearing a sport coat. And all of that was very intentional by me. I was like, look, he is attempting as best he can in his dockers and his like plaid-ish, like very ordinary jackets. He's putting it together. He has his tie on. It's not loose.|||……我的意思是，甚至在你刚才提到的那个篮球场景中，凯文穿着一件运动上衣。所有这一切都是我刻意为之的。我当时想：看吧，他穿着卡其裤和那种格子图案的、非常普通的夹克，正在竭尽全力地打扮自己。他把衣服搭配在一起。他系着领带。领带并没有松垮。
Like he's putting it together. It may not work all the best. And so I think that there was a series of contradictions that was very interesting to me in that. Like that there are things that he is good at that you would not expect him to be good at. So yes, in terms of that, that was something in terms of the construction of the character that was really important to me. And the last thing I'll say is that the greatest, maybe insider writer's room joke about Kevin has to do with this very thing, which was Kevin was in a band. It was a police cover band.
Like he's putting it together. It may not work all the best. And so I think that there was a series of contradictions that was very interesting to me in that. Like that there are things that he is good at that you would not expect him to be good at. So yes, in terms of that, that was something in terms of the construction of the character that was really important to me. And the last thing I'll say is that the greatest, maybe insider writer's room joke about Kevin has to do with this very thing, which was Kevin was in a band. It was a police cover band.|||就像他在努力搭配好一样。效果可能不是最好的。所以我认为这里面有一系列非常有意思的矛盾。比如有些事情你意想不到他会擅长，但他偏偏很擅长。所以，是的，就这一点而言，在塑造这个角色时，这是对我非常重要的一点。我要说的最后一件事是，关于凯文的编剧室内部笑话中，最棒的一个可能与此有关，那就是凯文曾在一个乐队里。那是一个警察乐队的翻唱乐队。
he played the drums and was the lead singer. However, now I didn't know this, but this is their joke. In the police, the singing happens off of the beat of the drums. So for a person to be a drummer, lead singer, you would literally have to be a musical savant to be able to sing off of the beat of the drums that you're playing. So that was sort of like a, I don't know, like an encapsulation of the idea that I did want for him. Yeah.
he played the drums and was the lead singer. However, now I didn't know this, but this is their joke. In the police, the singing happens off of the beat of the drums. So for a person to be a drummer, lead singer, you would literally have to be a musical savant to be able to sing off of the beat of the drums that you're playing. So that was sort of like a, I don't know, like an encapsulation of the idea that I did want for him. Yeah.|||他打鼓并担任主唱。然而，现在我不知道这一点，但这是他们的笑话。在警察乐队（The Police）的音乐中，歌唱往往与鼓点的拍子是错开的（off-beat）。所以对于一个人来说，要既当鼓手又当主唱，你简直必须是一个音乐奇才，才能在自己敲击的鼓点之外错拍进行演唱。所以这有点像……我不知道，这概括了我确实想赋予他的特质。是的。
I didn't want it to be not that stereotype. Kevin. Like immediately like, oh, we get who that is. What about like family of origin stuff? We never meet Kevin's family. Yeah. Did you have anything in your head about that? No.
I didn't want it to be not that stereotype. Kevin. Like immediately like, oh, we get who that is. What about like family of origin stuff? We never meet Kevin's family. Yeah. Did you have anything in your head about that? No.|||我不希望他落入那种刻板印象的凯文。就像那种让人立刻觉得“哦，我们知道那是个什么样的人”。那关于原生家庭之类的事情呢？我们从未见过凯文的家人。是的。你脑子里有什么关于这方面的想法吗？没有。
No. Not really. The Irish thing was important, and I know that I came up with that, but that was more regional than anything else. And the relationship, the idea behind the relationship is not revealed for a while, but that was something that we talked about, which I did think about. Like, where does he go when he goes home? And again, the idea of not wanting it to be necessarily what you would expect. Like, oh, he is going home to a person. a partner and oh, there's actually a child there.
No. Not really. The Irish thing was important, and I know that I came up with that, but that was more regional than anything else. And the relationship, the idea behind the relationship is not revealed for a while, but that was something that we talked about, which I did think about. Like, where does he go when he goes home? And again, the idea of not wanting it to be necessarily what you would expect. Like, oh, he is going home to a person. a partner and oh, there's actually a child there.|||没有。其实没有。爱尔兰人的设定很重要，我知道是我提出的，但那更多是出于地域特色而非其他。至于那段恋爱关系，恋爱背后的构思有一段时间没有揭晓，但那是我们讨论过的事情，我也确实思考过。比如，他回家时会去哪里？同样，这个想法是不希望它必然呈现出你所预料的样子。比如，哦，他是回家面对一个人，一个伴侣，哦，结果那里竟然还有一个孩子。
You know, all of those things again. But in terms of like, no, like parents and stuff, that was another thing I thought about. Brian, do you remember because we were over there in the little accounting nook and the writers would come over and say, hey. And I'll never forget one time I said, we were talking about this very thing. And I said, I really want to see where Kevin goes when he goes home or I want to see where people live. And I forgot, I think it was maybe BJ. And he goes, Angela, it's called The Office. I was like, okay.
You know, all of those things again. But in terms of like, no, like parents and stuff, that was another thing I thought about. Brian, do you remember because we were over there in the little accounting nook and the writers would come over and say, hey. And I'll never forget one time I said, we were talking about this very thing. And I said, I really want to see where Kevin goes when he goes home or I want to see where people live. And I forgot, I think it was maybe BJ. And he goes, Angela, it's called The Office. I was like, okay.|||你知道，又是所有这些事情。但就父母之类的事情而言，那是我想到的另一件事。布莱恩，你还记得吗，因为我们当时坐在那个小小的会计角落里，编剧们会走过来打招呼。我永远不会忘记有一次我说，我们当时正在谈论这件事，我说，我真的很想看看凯文回家后去哪里，或者我想看看大家住在哪里。我忘了，好像是 BJ（B.J. Novak）。他说：安吉拉，这剧叫《办公室》。我当时想：好吧。
All right, fair enough. It's not modern family. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have a question for you. Was there ever a Kevin storyline that you pitched that never made it in an episode, but you wish it had? Yes. I pitched pretty hard.
All right, fair enough. It's not modern family. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have a question for you. Was there ever a Kevin storyline that you pitched that never made it in an episode, but you wish it had? Yes. I pitched pretty hard.|||好吧，有道理。这不是《摩登家庭》。是的。是的。嗯，我有一个问题想问你。你曾提出过什么凯文的故事情节，但最终没能拍成剧集，而你希望它能拍成吗？是的。我曾极力推销过这个想法。
And I don't remember if it was at this point. moment in time, if this was pre-season 8 or 9, there had definitely been a romantic, somewhat a story between Aaron and Andy. I pitched that Kevin and Aaron got together. That was my pitch. Because I thought
And I don't remember if it was at this point. moment in time, if this was pre-season 8 or 9, there had definitely been a romantic, somewhat a story between Aaron and Andy. I pitched that Kevin and Aaron got together. That was my pitch. Because I thought|||我不记得当时具体是什么时间点了，如果是在第八季或第九季之前的话，艾伦（Erin）和安迪之间确实有过一段浪漫的、某种程度上的故事。我当时提议让凯文和艾伦在一起。这就是我的提案。因为我觉得……
that sort of, again, one of the things I felt like the show did really well was put together couples that weren't necessarily that you wouldn't necessarily think about. And the idea of Kevin
that sort of, again, one of the things I felt like the show did really well was put together couples that weren't necessarily that you wouldn't necessarily think about. And the idea of Kevin|||……这种设定再次体现了——我一直觉得这部剧做得非常出色的一点，就是把那些你可能根本不会联想到一起的情侣撮合在一起。而凯文的构想……
as a tree trunk and Aaron as this hummingbird nonstop energy that just continued to flit around my pitch was for them to get together. They didn't do it. That would have been hilarious. I would have loved to see the two of them on a date.
as a tree trunk and Aaron as this hummingbird nonstop energy that just continued to flit around my pitch was for them to get together. They didn't do it. That would have been hilarious. I would have loved to see the two of them on a date.|||……就像一根树干，而艾伦就像是一只拥有永动机般活力的小蜂鸟，一直在周围飞来飞去。我的提议就是让他们俩在一起。他们最后没拍这一段。那肯定会超级搞笑。我很想看看他们两个约会的场面。
That's, by the way, I shared that with Ellie when I had a conversation with her on my podcast and she at least publicly said the same thing. There was an episode, though, where for a minute, Kevin thinks he is going to date Aaron. Yes.
That's, by the way, I shared that with Ellie when I had a conversation with her on my podcast and she at least publicly said the same thing. There was an episode, though, where for a minute, Kevin thinks he is going to date Aaron. Yes.|||顺便说一句，我在我的播客里和艾莉（Ellie，即饰演Erin的Ellie Kemper）交谈时分享过这个想法，她至少在公开场合也表达了同样的看法。不过确实有一集，凯文曾一度以为自己要和艾伦约会。是的。
And I can't remember if that came out. I mean, I was basically told no. I don't think we were told all that often to stay in your lane. But they had this idea for Andy and Aaron, which I think ultimately I'm not sure worked out the way that they had thought that it was going to. And that I just felt like I saw early on. I just felt like there was a lot of comedic possibility in that.
我记不清那是怎么出来的了。我的意思是，我基本上被告知不行。我不觉得我们经常被告知要安分守己。但他们对安迪和亚伦有个想法，我觉得最终我不确定事情的发展是否如他们所料。我觉得我从一开始就看出来了。我只是觉得里面有很多喜剧的可能性。
And I feel like they were potentially looking for, I mean, it's probably, and I don't know. So I shouldn't speak to it, but a sort of Jim and Pam 2.0 potentially or something, but I felt like Aaron was so strong. I mean, her characterization was so strong and so specifically, well, like a hummingbird. And Andy was different. I just, I felt like they were mismatched. I think ultimately the show says that they were mismatched. And I just thought, yeah, that was, that's, that was my one pitch. Is there a line of dialogue or a talking head that you think embodies the character of Kevin?
我觉得他们可能在寻找，我的意思是，这可能是，我也不知道。所以我不用多说，但可能类似于吉姆和帕姆2.0版之类的，但我觉得亚伦太棒了。我是说，她的角色塑造太棒了，而且非常具体，就像一只蜂鸟。而安迪则不同。我只是觉得他们很不般配。我觉得最终剧集也表明他们很不般配。我只是觉得，对，那是，那就是，那是我的唯一建议。你认为哪句台词或单人访谈最能体现凯文这个角色的特质？
The two that jumped into my head really quickly, I'll share with you, but there's not my final answer. The first one that popped into my head was elemeno pee. The other one, then it suddenly went to, you can't eat cats. You can't eat cats, Kevin. Those two made me laugh more than any other ones. My favorite, and maybe because it's so fresh in my mind, Brian, is when Kevin goes, Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip.
迅速跳进我脑海的两个，我会跟你分享，但这不是我的最终答案。第一个跳进我脑海的是“elemeno pee”（埃勒梅诺P）。另一个是，突然变成了，你不能吃猫。你不能吃猫，凯文。这两个让我笑得比其他任何都多。我最喜欢的，也许是因为它在我脑海里还很新鲜，布赖恩，是凯文说，“菲利普，菲利普，菲利普”。一切都是为了菲利普。
I hate Philip. I think about that every time I hear the word Philip, actually. I guess for me, this is the cheesy answer. This is the more serious answer would be it's just nice to win one. Oh, that was a great one. Yeah. Yeah. I think that that does embody Kevin, I think. Yeah. Right? Yeah. I think that's, I think that's the answer. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Our final question is something that Zach Woods asked us when we interviewed him. Which he ended up interviewing us and it was fantastic. But I love it. And it is this. If you could go back and relive any moment from our.
我讨厌菲利普。其实每次听到“菲利普”这个词，我都会想到那个。我想对我来说，这是一个俗气的回答。更严肃的回答可能是，能赢一次真好。哦，那是个极好的。对。对。我觉得那个确实体现了凯文，我觉得。是吧？对。我觉得那就是，我觉得那就是答案。对。对。好吧。我们的最后一个问题是扎克·伍兹在我们采访他时问我们的。他最后采访了我们，这太棒了。但我喜欢它。它是这样的：如果你能回到过去，重新体验我们在一起的任何时刻。
nine years together on the office, and I guess specifically playing Kevin, since this is all about Kevin Malone. Okay. What would you like to relive or re-experience? Wow. As playing Kevin. Well, I mean, I guess since this is all about Kevin Malone, but you can tell us as Brian, too. Yeah, if there was a day you could go back to on the set.
在《办公室》共度的九年时光，我猜特别是扮演凯文，因为这一切都是关于凯文·马隆的。好的。你想重新体验什么？哇。作为扮演凯文。好吧，我的意思是，既然这一切都是关于凯文·马隆的，但你也可以以布赖恩的身份告诉我们。是的，如果有一天你可以回到片场。
Not being in the swimming pool. That was the worst. That was horrible. We know what you don't want to do. Yeah. I'm going to give a couple of those. Not being in the parking lot for any number of episodes, but specifically I remember the fire episode. It was so hot.
不要在游泳池里。那是相当糟糕的。那太可怕了。我们知道你不想做什么。好的。我要说几个。不要在任何剧集的停车场里，特别是我记得火灾那一集。太热了。
So hot. Just like so horrifying. Because we didn't have chairs. We didn't have chairs. So we didn't ever sit. We didn't sit. just stood on that black top. My shoes melting.
太热了。简直太可怕了。因为我们没有椅子。我们没有椅子。所以我们从来不坐。我们没有坐。只是站在那沥青地上。我的鞋子都融化了。
And we had to look up and it was so hot. Yeah. Okay. So we're not reliving those. Not those. Not, you know, spoiler alert, Kevin did a lot of physical comedy in the show and like big things where I was never injured. When we worked in the warehouse and we put oil on the ground and we were sliding things. And then there was a.
而且我们不得不抬头看，天气太热了。好的。所以我们不会重温那些。不是那些。你知道的，剧透警告，凯文在剧中有很多形体喜剧，还有一些大场面，但我从来没有受伤。我们在仓库工作的时候，我们在地上倒了油，我们在滑东西。然后有一个。
talking head where I think it was John and Rain, Jim and Dwight talking on a sofa. It was definitely one of them, maybe both of them, like together. And it was, oh, just walk behind them and then slip and disappear. My back still hurts from that just like, because it was like, and I had to go down fast. Yeah. That was not my favorite. I love that I'm just answering not what my not favorites were. I feel like the moment you want to relive is the scene with Pam, um, played by just the amazing Jenna Fisher. God, she was so good, wasn't she? Yeah. Yeah. Or maybe, um, you had a scene in accounting with the just comedic talent that is Angela Kinsey. Yeah. Not sure how you pick between the two. I don't remember her. Um, do you know what one of my favorites, Brian? And this,
单人访谈，我想那是约翰和雷恩，吉姆和德怀特在沙发上谈话。绝对是他们中的一个，也许是他们两个一起。就是，哦，只要走到他们身后然后滑倒并消失。我的背现在想起来还隐隐作痛，因为那是，而且我必须快速倒下。是的。那不是我最喜欢的。我喜欢我只是在回答我不是最喜欢的那些。我觉得你想重温的时刻是和帕姆的场景，嗯，由出色的珍娜·费舍尔扮演。天哪，她太棒了，不是吗？对。对。或者也许，嗯，你在会计部有一个场景，和喜剧天才安吉拉·金西。对。不确定你怎么在两者之间做出选择。我不记得她了。嗯，你知道我最喜欢的一个吗，布赖恩？还有这个，
like was just us being ridiculous because we were always messing with each other like we said. But I'll never forget that time where I was just supposed to say to Oscar something about payroll and you turned and bumped into me by accident. And when you hit me, I went back. You body checked me. And we started laughing so hard. And they were like, no, keep that in. So every time he bumped into me.
就像我们只是在搞笑，因为我们总是像我们说的那样捉弄对方。但我永远不会忘记那次，我本该对奥斯卡说点关于工资的事，你转过身不小心撞到了我。当你撞到我时，我往后退了。你用身体撞了我。我们开始笑得喘不过气来。他们说，不，把那个留着。所以每次他撞到我，
and I would go payroll. Yeah. I got in trouble for that over the year, because then we started doing that a little bit over the years. And then, yeah, you would get hurt sometimes. And then you push me into a hedge. I know what you want to relive. Okay.
我就会说“工资”。是的。这些年来我为此惹过麻烦，因为后来这些年我们开始经常那样做了。然后，是的，你有时会受伤。然后你把我推到树篱里。我知道你想重温什么。好的。
Work bus. Oh, probably. That's another one where we all almost died. That one? Yeah. That one. Oh, Brian Branson. I don't know.
工作巴士。哦，可能吧。那是另一个我们差点都死掉的。那个？对。那个。哦，布赖恩·布兰森。我不知道。
You don't want to relive anything. You're like I did it. Stop trying to make me go back there. No. Look, I think that for me, I mean, there's like the easy answer now, right? Which is like the chilly one, which again, was all alone when no one else was there. Also, your hands were stained. That was great.
你什么都不想重温。你好像在说我做过了。别再试图让我回去了。不。听着，我觉得对我来说，我的意思是，现在有一个简单的答案，对吧？也就是辣汤那个，再次强调，那是当没有其他人在场时独自完成的。还有，你的手都染上色了。那太棒了。
Your hands were stained for so long. I think that for me, in terms of Kevin, the unique experience as an actor playing that role with. everybody in that space. So it's not a specific scene or a moment, but those scenes, not so much the conference room, the conference room. I mean,
你的手被染色了好久。我觉得对我来说，就凯文而言，作为一个演员在那个空间里和所有人一起扮演这个角色的独特经历。所以这不是一个特定的场景或时刻，而是那些场景，与其说是会议室，不如说是会议室。我的意思是，
although that intimacy, I thought, brought amazing comedy. Thinking about some of those scenes, Steve walking out of his office, or walking in that perspective, walking in the front door of Dunder Mifflin, and there being this group scene and just like, you know,
尽管那种亲密感，我认为带来了惊人的喜剧效果。想到其中一些场景，史蒂夫走出办公室，或者从那个视角走进来，走进了邓德米弗林的的前门，那里有一个群体场景，就像，你知道的，
the image of a ball being thrown around to everybody in different things. Like that experience, which only came, which only came because we were in a confined space all there for so much time together. I firmly believe that
球在每个人之间传来传去的画面。那样的经历，只有在，只有在我们呆在一个密闭空间里共度那么多时间的情况下才会产生。我坚信
because it is about amazing writing and writers that write to your characters. but the way that we were able to learn each other's strengths and comedic sensibility, that I think is, like, Kevin would miss that. I mean, he was fired, so he's no longer there. You're in Austin, by the way. I know. I know knows where she is.
因为这是关于精彩的剧本和为你的角色写剧本的编剧，但我们能够了解彼此的长处和喜剧敏感度的方式，我觉得，就像，凯文会怀念这一点的。我是说，他被解雇了，所以他不在那里了。顺便说一句，你在奥斯汀。我知道。我知道她在哪。
I'm on a beet farm. But Kevin misses that. I do want to, I do have to tell you this because this was the first thing that popped into my mind and sometimes that's the best or the worst. like overall like Brian thing that I wish that I could relive was that first Golden Globe thing like that first experience of the Golden Globe and David Denman driving from my house where we were pre-gaming. Angela was there in the hills above Beverly Hills and us driving. to the Golden Globes in my recollection, a Honda Civic, driven by David Denman, and thinking we were just going to be allowed to there.
我在一个甜菜农场。但凯文很怀念这一点。我确实想，我不得不告诉你这个，因为这是最先跳入我脑海的事情，有时那是最好或最糟的。就像整体上的，我希望能够重温的“布赖恩式”的事情是那次第一次金球奖的事情，就像第一次经历金球奖，还有大卫·邓曼从我家开车，我们在那之前预热。安吉拉就在比弗利山庄上方的山丘上，我们开车去金球奖，在我的记忆中，是一辆由大卫·邓曼驾驶的本田思域，以为我们只会被允许去那里。
Well, by the way, not the Golden Globes, a party in a garage. Well, correct. On the top of a parking garage adjacent to. We've never stepped foot in the actual Golden Globes. And maybe that's why. but us like getting out on Wilshire Boulevard and him being like, all right, I'll go find a parking spot because we kind of realized there's no valet at the golden, like you get dropped off. We could even make it into the hotel valet because we didn't have a security placard. We had nothing.
顺便说一句，不是金球奖，是一个车库里的派对。好吧，没错。在毗邻的停车场顶层。我们从未涉足真正的金球奖。也许这就是原因。但我们就像在威尔希尔大道下车，他说，好吧，我去停车场找个车位，因为我们有点意识到金球奖没有代客泊车，就像你被送到那。我们甚至无法进入酒店的代客泊车处，因为我们没有安全停车证。我们什么都没有。
We had nothing. But that night and how much fun it was when I think back about at least the like extracurriculars around the show. So like that one, that was just like the best. The best. Yeah. Oh, thanks, Brian. Thanks for talking all about Kevin Malone. This has got to be the greatest episode.
我们什么都没有。但那天晚上以及当我回想起至少与剧集相关的课外活动时，它是多么有趣。所以就像那个，那简直就是最好的。最好的。哦，谢谢你，布赖恩。谢谢你谈论凯文·马隆的一切。这绝对是最棒的一集。
Let me know how it goes. Okay. Thanks, B. Angela, I loved that. I know. And I am also really loving these character breakdown episodes. I hope we can have more cast members come on their character breakdown episodes. I do too.
告诉我进展如何。好的。谢谢，B。安吉拉，我喜欢那个。我知道。而且我也真的很喜欢这些角色剖析剧集。我希望我们能有更多演员来他们的角色剖析剧集。我也希望如此。
It's one, it's so much fun to see everyone. And then two, I love hearing everyone's thoughts about their character. We got so attached to these people. Yeah. Yeah. Well, before we go, I wanted to share one last fan letter. It is from Miles D in Virginia. Miles says, hi, ladies, day one listener.
首先，能看到每个人太有趣了。其次，我喜欢听每个人对他们角色的看法。我们对这些人产生了如此深厚的感情。对。对。好吧，在我们离开之前，我想分享最后一封粉丝信。这是来自弗吉尼亚州的迈尔斯D。迈尔斯说，嗨，女士们，我是第一天的听众。
First time emailer. I'm listening to episode two of Office Lady 6.0 all about Michael Scott and your discussion of real life people with names of famous people slash fictional characters. and it reminded me of my high school geometry teacher. He was a slim, handsome man who looked like Michael Boubley, but was named Kevin Malone. Oh my goodness. Luckily for him, the office was just a couple years away from making its resurgence, or he would have been the butt of many jokes.
第一次发邮件。我正在听《办公室女士》6.0版的第二集，全部关于迈克尔·斯科特以及你们对现实生活中拥有名人/虚构角色名字的人的讨论，这让我想起了我的高中几何老师。他是一个身材苗条、长相帅气的男人，看起来像迈克尔·布雷，但名字叫凯文·马隆。哦，天哪。幸运的是，对于他来说，《办公室》距离东山再起只有几年时间，否则他会成为许多笑柄的笑料。
That being said, he was a kind, fair teacher, but we all knew he was not to be truffled with. Thank you, ladies, for this podcast and for the office. its effect on me and my sense of humor has been incalculable. And anytime I watch the show or listen to the podcast, it feels like a warm blanket. Oh my goodness. Miles, I love that you wrote in about your geometry teacher named Kevin Malone. I know. Aw. Well, what a great way to end this episode.
话虽如此，他是一位善良、公正的老师，但我们都知道他是惹不起的。谢谢女士们制作了这个播客和《办公室》。它对我和我的幽默感的影响是无法估量的。任何时候我看这部剧或听播客，都感觉像是一条温暖的毯子。哦，天哪。迈尔斯，我很高兴你写信讲述了你的几何老师名叫凯文·马隆。我知道。哦。好吧，这是结束这一集的绝佳方式。
Thank you all so much for sending in your questions and comments. And a big thank you to Brian Baumgartner for stopping by the studio. to talk with us. Yes, I'm going to share in our Instagram stories where you can get his seriously good chili cookbook and it is real good. Seriously good. Seriously good. All right, everyone. Thanks for listening and have a great week. Thanks, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Burman and Leah
非常感谢大家发送你们的问题和评论。非常感谢布赖恩·巴姆加特纳来到工作室和我们交谈。是的，我将在我们的Instagram快拍中分享你可以在哪里买到他那本真的很好吃的辣椒食谱，它真的很好吃。真的很好吃。真的很好吃。好了，各位。谢谢收听，祝你们度过愉快的一周。谢谢你们，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubicoe）。奥德赛的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼（Jenna Weiss-Burman）和莉亚
Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔（Chris Basil）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡皮树》（Rubber Tree）。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。